let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
well hello early in the morning
welcome welcome welcome to a special
edition a live edition of as we react to
the marjorie hoof foot green
marjory taylor green
hearings
they have just they have just commenced
they are standing up right now
as you see them um let's let's turn up
the the volume here and see if we can
hear
we are going to react live
to this hearing um if you guys
don't know marjorie taylor green is
being questioned rather she can run for
her seat
it's really hard to hear they don't have
this mic worth a damn
there's marjorie taylor green setting up
they all cheered
as she entered the room
um you know in pure fascist style yay
yay the foot's here
as a an attorney in a prosecutor it
spent time in a courtroom um when she
came in they all cheered yeah yeah yeah
the fascist is here and then um she sat
down and they're going through you know
some of the rules and stuff i'm sure
like hey this is a very important
proceeding that sort of thing can you
tell us as we listen in
what why this is so important
absolutely i mean this is a i would say
an unprecedented
uh court proceeding or hearing i mean i
think the whole world is going to watch
this because this is a very
unique
um kind of hearing you know these types
of disqualification hearings are usually
things about is the person
old enough or you know it's it's
disputes about things you know things
like that here this is
this is this is the kind of
disqualification hearing that i don't
think anyone's ever seen or or
watched before and i think a lot of
people are tuning in to see what exactly
are they going to ask her what's the
proceeding going to be like is she going
to testify is she going to be put under
oath
she testifies
yeah so this is like like most court
proceedings um that you don't see on law
and order
uh
they they
there's this whole there there are some
rules and procedural things that all
judges do
at the beginning of any whether it's a
hearing or a trial you know they sort of
it's almost ministerial you know things
that just have to be done and that's
what this judge appears to be doing
right now
um so we'll see you know we'll we'll see
this this doesn't
to my knowledge this hasn't really
happened in our lifetimes right like not
to my knowledge i mean it's it's not
something that we know about i mean so a
lot of people have questions what what's
the burden of proof what's this what are
the what type of evidence are they going
to put on is she going to testify right
is she going to
um be put under oath you know and swear
to tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
and the reason you swear people under
oath is so that if they don't tell the
truth you later potentially could
prosecute them for perjury
so i mean it's you know this is serious
this is a very serious proceeding
because
you know it's at the very core of our
democracy whether someone gets to be put
on a ballot and run for office or not i
mean this is a really important
really important thing that's happening
here you know i have questions about
about how
how
what do they have to prove or to show to
um call her an insurrectionist or you
know to
or or to say she engaged in insurrection
and then therefore be in violation of
the 14th amendment of the constitution
you know is it is it do you have to be
convicted of it or is it enough to just
show that you participated in it or what
kind of finding does the judge have to
make here so so all of these things are
are sort of interesting and and maybe
the judge is talking about it right now
and explaining these things and perhaps
we should listen let me let me turn it
up and we'll listen 36 p-55
p-57 it sounds like he's auctioning
cattle i don't know this is what uh when
i was younger this is you know
you'd have the uh all the cattle would
be tagged as numbers and letters so that
you could keep track of the inventory so
i don't know what he's doing here but i
thought we walked into a bingo game so
yeah
bingo
barely looks like a courtroom i mean it
clearly is bad
363 e64 p65
when when marjorie taylor green did
enter the room everyone started cheering
um
because she's obviously stacked in the
room with uh
a piece of before with her fans i'm sure
courtroom
[Music]
yeah but you know what i don't like
about it i'm about to criticize it
if i'm if you're right-handed like most
people are oh you don't get it it's on
the wrong side it's on the wrong side so
i can't even shamelessly promote it by
just drinking you know
the suits we'll call the suits we'll
call this [ __ ]
these p15s p20s these must be pieces of
evidence that they're submitting yeah so
p
probably hears uh stands for plaintiff
um so
that's how you that's how you would
distinguish
like so for example in a criminal case a
criminal federal case you would the
prosecutor's exhibits would be
gx one so government exhibit one
or dx
20 you know defense exhibit 20. so in
here the plaintiff is the person suing
marjorie taylor green so that she can't
re-run for her seat exactly
exactly so this is this is a um
this is a group of people who have come
together who are the plaintiff and and
suing her saying she's not qualified
it's five people right
i i'm not sure actually yesterday
i'm not sure how many times
what they're doing now is
trying so in order to admit an exhibit
in real life
you have to ask a bunch of foundation
questions you know do you recognize this
what do you recognize this to be is this
a fair and accurate depiction of level
you know
and it and i think what they're trying
to do is
get as many documents and exhibits into
evidence as you can
that both sides agree on and so that
you're saying the plaintiffs are trying
to admit these into i think both sides
typically what they do is let's let's
all agree with what are all the exhibits
let's make the arguments now so that
when we ask questions of the witnesses i
don't have to sit here and do all these
foundational questions that can take
forever and they're very tedious so
they're probably right now they're doing
some streamlining to try to make things
more efficient
so kind of like jury selection you both
have to agree that
this is the actual juror that you're
okay with yeah if if you want to agree
in advance of the things that you're
going to admit and then you ask the
judge you know and the judge is right
now ruling on what he is going to
say yes or no
can this come in can this not has the
has the judge reviewed this evidence
beforehand or is he just kind of like
offhand based on the description he's
being given right now
just being so okay
he mentioned that uh he did this
yesterday so
um
i would assume that he's reviewed it all
and that he get arguments from both
sides as to
what things are and why but here we go i
think we're about to
we're about to begin as we discussed as
we've discussed we're going to proceed
i'm going to i'd like to begin with
these statements uh well before we begin
anything uh
miss bob anything that you want to
discuss before we start building stuff
right
mr shelly we're right here all right
good she urged and encouraged to help
facilitate violent resistance to our own
government
our democracy and our constitution and
in doing so she engaged in exactly the
type of conduct that triggers
disqualification under section 3 of the
14th amendment which is to say she
engaged in insurrection
thank you
thank you
you should have spent more time
talking about what she did i i'm
concerned about the evidence because he
didn't really talk about what she did
and he should have i mean it's clear
there was an insurrection
it's clear that
uh
you know all of the elements are there
except what about her and i'm concerned
that the most he said was she used coded
language right yeah i mean yeah
mentioned that a few times yeah so i i'm
like see what the evidence is but this
i'm already a little concerned the
reason he's
talking about incitement or it's engaged
is because
incitement is the type of speech you're
actually not the first amendment does
not protect
you so that's why he's going down this
this hole
that the supreme court has said
so in other words insurrection is not
protected by the first amendment is
supreme court because the first one
correct well he's saying well
insurrection is not protected but he's
saying it requires conduct or requires
you to do something right and the
plaintiff or the the petitioner's theory
is that the words here was was the
action it was the doing something
and he's saying no the words are free
speech but the thing is you're
the the right to free speech is not
unlimited so for example i can't run
into you know the example that's been
given
historically is i can't run into a
crowded movie theater and scream that
there's a fire
and then people run out and get trampled
you know and i say oh free speech i can
say whatever i want you're not allowed
to do certain
speech is not unlimited protected and
one of the things that is not allowed is
something called incitement like to
incite violence to encourage violence to
incite a riot you know so that's one of
the exceptions that you're not allowed
to do so what he's trying to do is
thread this little needle
saying that
that to incite is not the same as to
engage because this because it says
engage in an insurrection it doesn't say
incite an insurrection it's
very interesting you know and right
continue to listen but you know the
first thing that comes to mind in this
is is a general concept that i would say
you know if when you're on the defense
if you've got the facts on your side you
argue the facts if you but if you don't
have the facts on your side then you go
to the law
so far all he's talked about is the law
right yeah that signals to me that he's
worried about the facts yeah he's done
he's done a lot of
he's he's debating semantics right now
he's like it's not they said and it says
or
no he's arguing about an and versus nor
you're absolutely right so that signals
like i said that he's worried about the
facts well because the facts are is that
marjorie taylor green did use her speech
to incite right yeah i mean i mean so
could you look at the video that was the
night before when she comes out she's
like hey everyone just had a meeting i'm
really excited about you know like uh
not certifying the election like would
you consider that like obviously it
wasn't on january 6th but would you
consider that absolutely absolutely yeah
that's really important you know the
other thing that i thought was
interesting was he was saying anything
before january 3rd she hadn't taken the
oath yet so you know so so because she
wasn't a sitting person of correct and
they're right that still doesn't mean
she wasn't inciting an insurrection yeah
but she's allowed to that's what he's
saying that maybe not maybe she could be
maybe so you're allowed you're allowed
to incite an insurrection if you're
i'd say a federal court might have
something to say about that so you're so
there's two separate issues right she
could be prosecuted for it right but
he's specifically saying it doesn't
disqualify her from
holding office because this is all about
disqualification for holding office
right
this is a civil case another thing it's
not even civil it's administrative
one of the other arguments he made was
we're not even in civil court he's like
this is an administrative proceeding so
you know there's a lot to unpack and i'm
taking notes so i don't forget to say
any of these things when you know when
we have a downtime and i don't mean to
be not no go ahead listen
he's very monitoring he's not debating
much here
but but he's he's like i said he's
focusing on the law and on these legal
because he wants to hang his hat on the
fact that you know
that basically
it says and not or says or not and i
mean he's really threading a needle here
to try to get the judge to to get her on
this ballot he's saying because the
judge makes the decision right like
there's no jury there's no jury here
right correct because the other thing
here that he's saying is he's he had the
whole argument before he went into
semantics he was like well it's their
right to have someone on the ballot but
i could also argue that the guy in north
dakota who died of copen in 2020 was
still on the ballot and he won
so i'm pretty sure there's precedent for
people who have not run through various
means in terms of being able to hold
office yeah so he's
yes and he's making a few arguments he's
saying
judge you're the wrong this is the wrong
place to have this argument this
argument belongs either in civil court
where we can discuss the constitution
and her constitutional rights
or to congress you know once she's
elected you go to congress and then you
try to disqualify her so he's trying to
just get her on the ballot and get her
elected and then get the can down to
congress to make the argument there
he's also saying that he's when he says
that the law requires you to be sworn
and then
um
and then you you know you swear to
uphold the constitution and then you
can't engage in an insurrection that
he's saying she wasn't sworn until
january 3rd therefore everything before
that's irrelevant to whether she can be
on the ballot and he's saying that
because he wants to do that and he's so
he or criminal but not right but not
anything regarding the election so he's
saying that in order to prevent and
preclude any evidence because i i there
must be things before january 3rd i'm
sure you can find something but isn't
there isn't there a case to be made even
though she hadn't taken the oath she had
already her vote had already been
certified right right so i mean even
though she hadn't stood there and took
the oath she still was no she has to
take the oath but i would still make the
argument that it's relevant towards her
intent on january 6. whether that
conduct was
technically i would say it's still
admissible and relevant you know but
that's why he's i'm just telling you why
he's saying that
transfer to someone else right anyway so
those are sort of
the thoughts i have so far but why don't
we do that
yeah i don't know what that is when a
heckler i think it's i think it's on the
uh the broadcasting
let me meet my mic and see the congress
uh you know the house and they have to
suspend
it's gone now
but that person must beat me
my dog is snoring underneath my like
right here underneath my desk too so
um i don't know what that maybe maybe
it's the dog snoring yeah
but i would say the other thing he moved
now so we might have that the other
thing about this too is like
you could you know you could argue all
you want to say she wasn't a city man or
a member of congress so you know she
should still be on the ballot but the
same time it's like well i can also
demonstrate intent right like she ran
for office she knew she won
yep and just like just like lauren
bobert and her you know uh
capital tours and what have you like
there's there's intent there there was
planning and intent before
taking office all right there's a
transition period here where you were
elected and you took office and you knew
exactly what you were going to do
what you were going to say and how you
were going to act like here's the thing
two days after she's elected she's
already having meetings about january
6th with the president of the united
states
it seems like something's going on here
that yeah
i mean look and the other thing too is
you know and and the the judge said this
in the beginning he said the burden of
proof so what the petitioner has to
prove
is um is that you know she's not
qualified by a preponderance of the
evidence and that's what that means is
so there's different burdens of proof so
in a criminal case you have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt so that's the
highest burden of proof
to prove something by the preponderance
of the evidence that's literally just
greater than 50
so
it's like you know you can put a feather
on a scale and it tips it to 50 points
01 and that's it you've met your burden
so it'll be interesting it's not a high
burden that the petitioner has to prove
here and finally
let's let's uh listen and see what he
says he's saying what yeah
juxtaposed what the insurrection is and
what an insurrection isn't
it says an insurrection is an organized
and armed uprising against authority or
operation
of government i'm sorry there is zero
doubt that this was an insurrection
right here
in the insurrection but there was an
insurrection well because she doesn't
have that
right she doesn't have to actually carry
the guns right like like it wasn't in
direction
right she didn't have to like swing the
gun on her back and go into the to be
exactly
to me there's zero doubt that this was
an insurrection the only question is was
she engaged well and red of this judge
will agree with that too i guess the
other question
let's listen
now
we have stipulated
that
a group of people this judge's life
by the way this is like central casting
old white guys you know
all three like the the petitioner's
lawyer the defense lawyer it's just well
the the the defense lawyer put my dog to
sleep um
he's he's moved now but he was snoring
right underneath my feet and i didn't
realize it because i had my headphones
on but gabe pointed it out to me
privately and
so he even put my dog to sleep
i don't know
as a woman lawyer it just i wish
sometimes it wasn't it wasn't this all
the time right the judge too
yeah if there is conduct
that meets the term engagement it
probably does smell really like
mothballs
real close to the front there
i would imagine breaking into the
capital that would be an engagement
sorry
did your grandparents smell like balls
my grandparents smelled like they would
keep a bag of mothballs in the i don't
know they had mothballs in the drawers
yeah clothes smell like that so yeah
there was happened to all the moths that
used to exist
so this this is very important so i urge
you to speak yeah but what's it i want
to know what the time stamp of that
tweet is
at what point did she give in and say oh
we have to listen to trump obviously
probably after the video i would imagine
god bless everyone
after the violent insurrection started
but i said it you know it's ridiculous i
said it was sorry yeah exactly right
i mean after
[Laughter]
i was almost burned alive
because i didn't know the way out
oh my god
[ __ ] ridiculous so
oh man
that's the uh
i was actually a potential target and
it's like
well if you didn't tell people to
fight the certification
oh my god he's finally done talking oh
he's finally done oh
he's finally done
so so uh snow fest there
seems to be a little over we're gonna
see what they're gonna do finally
finished what seemed like watching 17
hours
but it sounds like he's gonna give his
rebuttal here
there we go proceedings through their
undersigned counsel speculate that the
following facts are true
i try to understand the doctor so what's
happening right now is
they just read stipulations into the
record which means these are the facts
we all agree on so you don't have to
prove them this is the date she was
declared her candidacy this is the date
she was you know all these are all
technical elements of the crime
you know that that
otherwise they would have to prove
and so they're all agreeing that the
people went into the capitol
that it was paused for a certain period
of time so otherwise we'd be having
almost a full blown trial where they're
showing all of this over and over and
over again the stipulations mean
both sides agree and so you don't have
to prove those things
now what's happening is there's a
professor that they're putting on that
they're clearly trying to certify as an
expert
and so they're calling him as an expert
to talk about whatever he's going to
talk about i assume historical
precedence and what's it concerning
jackson and the period in which he was
president the second was the period at
the end of the 19th century one million
so this isn't a plaintiff this is an
expert witness
basically giving credit to the
plankton's
correct i think he's setting the setting
the context or setting the stage that
this is an insurrection because in his
opening statement he tried to say you
know there's certain insurrections which
was like the civil war but then he said
there are other types of insurrections
that don't necessarily constitute
technical wars like the whiskey
rebellion and you know he was he was
giving other examples so i think that's
what he's trying to show here that this
wasn't a military
organized military coup
type insurrection but this was a another
sort of type of insurrection and this
counts and so that's what they're trying
to show here that this was an
insurrection
i always i always call it the cheeto
exactly so they're trying to prove that
a this is an insurrection and then the
next thing that was true is that she had
engaged in the con
right she incited the insurrection and
2021 about the
bushrad washington book um and i've been
doing some other things related to so
that's why they're going through his
resume to so that they can certify him
as and if you're getting fellowships or
professional recognition for this work
yes i was a fellow at number one so this
is just this is just um the court
where i work giving him credibility
exactly on the record exactly and so so
there's something um there's a term of
art
in a courtroom called an expert witness
and it's it's it'll once you certify
someone an expert and you go through
these questions about their resumes to
make them an expert and once they're
certified as an expert
then they are allowed to give their
opinion
about something so they're gonna i i
guarantee they're gonna ask him what you
know in your opinion was what happened
on january 6 an insurrection
and if he were not an expert or he's not
certified as an expert his opinions
would not be allowed uh the only thing
that's allowed for a regular witness is
is facts you're allowed to give i saw
this i did this i
um witnessed that
so
but they're trying to allow get him to
be able to give opinion and that's why
they're going through this you know
what are your rewards and publications
and schooling and what
you know more of a historian than uh
than a lawyer in that respect
your honor this time i moved to tender
professor maguiaka as an expert witness
in 19th century american constitutional
history there you go
i inject your owner number one uh
so this is the battle rather he's an
expert or not yep
exactly
again like i said if he is bound to be
an expert he can give his opinion
uh so that we can prepare for his
testimony number three
uh he has not produced the to us
uh the documents that he relied upon in
order to reach whatever conclusions the
expert originally for funny this is why
as much as i love
uh law shows and you know they're sorry
the stories they pick are so interesting
i i literally can't watch them because
nothing ever happens the way they show
on these shows it's really this boring
you know technical kind of long drawn
out stuff you know
romanticized right i mean i wish it was
but well government government is is
very boring and that's really kind of
trump's shtick is that it's not boring
it's salacious it's you know that that
was always his draw and it's it's
reality tv in other words yeah and it's
really not that it really isn't so it's
true it seems ridiculous uh that they're
fighting over this because it's not like
a jury's here it's one thing to call an
expert in front of a jury and it means
something
i mean
you know the judge is gonna make his
decision he's hearing what you know he's
going to hear the facts he's going to
make his decision
it really is just theater i mean at this
point yeah i mean maybe there maybe he's
trying to preserve an appellate record i
have no idea you know to say the judge
was wrong in certifying this guy as a
witness but as an expert i should say
you have articles and authorities and
original documents that you wish to cite
i'm happy to read them
but the judge is saying you should have
put all this in your papers and argued
it being right but it's not appropriate
to just put it on as a witness without a
full legal analysis in papers
i will judge
yeah he's going to let him start and see
where he goes
but the judge basically saying i don't
want to be told what the law is by
someone else
is is this a federally appointed judge
or is this a state judge state this is a
state administration i just want to make
sure that everyone out there listening
knows that this is a georgia state judge
yes not a federal judge after the civil
war elections were held across the south
what happened to tarring and feather he
also shut down courts because again
it was a thing and now it's no longer a
thing like how does that happen
i i don't know feathers became real
expensive
there were four or five people
maybe maybe they're stopping and
stopping the feather trucks washington
in texas
from creating a shortage intentionally
that portion of pennsylvania what are
you saying about the whiskey rebellion
here seems pretty significant
and like
that it's loosely it was loosely
organized it wasn't like this grand
scheme
ordinary exactly that's what they're
trying to say
and this is where they're objecting
because it's it's starting to dig into
the facts here
if i recall your earlier testimony
correctly uh you said that
four people died in shades rebellion and
four or five in the whiskey resigned
all right jack i mean he's
going on with this
is to talk about something that was
around as level legislative
if they can get it deemed not in
insurrection americans
are they
are they able to use like we look at all
the other people who have been indicted
or you know convicted of america their
role in the insurgency may not use that
as president to say like we've
established this in the court already
correct
that's an interesting thing you're
making
nobody who's been charged with no
thought uh
six seven hundred eight hundred i can't
remember how many people were charged by
the department of justice not one has
been charged with the crime of
instruction there is a crime if they
establish this as precedent could then
other cases say well this
court already established it's an
insurrection
again this is not criminal right right
preponderance of the evidence not beyond
a reasonable doubt it's sort of
different
but you're making good points and that's
one of the curious questions is why
didn't the department of justice charge
all these other individuals with an
insurrection
um
we'll see
i believe this is our first piece of
evidence right that's been presented
this is going to be the first one
sort of i mean yes stipulations are
evident i mean you know yes this is
going to be probably the first thing we
see right
are you familiar with if this dictionary
has a definition for insurrection
yes it does
and what what can you without reading
from that uh that definition
is that i mean we didn't need an expert
to be called to read the dictionary
but
okay
is that what's happening here
essentially yeah
i mean look it courts often look to the
dictionary to find the quote-unquote
plain meaning of words
but
well they're helpful in putting terms
into context for example if i'm reading
a letter and i'm trying to understand
what somebody meant you know sometimes
the definition that people used back
then they're defining a definition and
defining a dictionary it's fine you know
it's again this is the the wheels of
justice
again government is boring it's very
boring like as boring as it would be to
read a dictionary even yeah
government can be boring
i i don't i'm not trying to offend
anyone i try to make government
interesting but you know and uh what are
we looking at here
which happens happens to all of us
i'm the judge sure
you know when the judge sort of say he
in fact we're actually passed by 10 45
right so let's take our break where we
can
stop you this is not a show do not
flapping
we will stop now well that's because
that's because marjorie taylor green
probably brought those people on the
court
to do that
to do that
right yeah but the judge just said this
is not a show do not clap this is a
scenario
actually i think that was i think that
was margaret taylor green's defense
attorney who stood up and said that
oh really yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna mute
this so so we'll play it here um while
we're talking um well i i i misspoke
we're not going to actually go to a
different link we're gonna stay here um
when we get ready here in about um an
hour and nine minutes we're just going
to replay the intro go into the podcast
if we're still um
going into
if the hearing is still going on then
we'll actually go ahead and just keep
broadcasting it and commenting um karen
you're welcome to stay or if you have to
go and i know you have some hard outs
here today um so so anytime you need to
you know cut out just just let us know
and but we do appreciate your
your analysis here so so far what do you
what do you think about
how this is turning out do you think
this is
um what what marjorie taylor green is
looking for or do you think that more of
this is what the plaintiff is looking
for in this
so
i i think that the the petitioner here
is um a little flustered and it happens
you know when you have a plan and it's
happened to me when you have a plan
about what you're going to uh present to
court and
you
you know you're completely prepared and
the judge basically cuts the legs out
from under you and says you know i'm not
interested in hearing about this this
should have been in your papers so
don't don't do this do something else
and and one of the things about being a
lawyer and a and a trial lawyer is you
have to be able to be nimble and
you know be on your feet and uh you know
think on your feet and be able to change
course pretty quickly and so i you saw
that kind of happen there and the judge
was very nice he said okay i see that
you're a little bit flustered there
right let's take a break let's take a
break and and judges do that you know
and it's a nice it's it's a nice thing
to do
there are some times judges aren't so
nice and and and make you sort of do it
anyway but so you know you're seeing
real life not actors not scripted kind
of what it's like to be a lawyer a
courtroom lawyer and a litigator so
really what the petitioner's lawyer is
going to do is they're going to um
regroup and
and try to reframe this witness to talk
about the things that the judge says i
will allow and not the other things that
uh that they won't allow but uh what
would concern me a little bit so far
about what i've seen is the petitioner
both the petitioner
and the um and marjorie taylor greens
lawyer
neither one of them have really talked
about the facts
so i i don't know who's more worried
about them you know so i i was hoping to
hear you know because there's so much
news about the insurrection and about
you know the
the who did what and and um you know i
don't know how many people could
actually say this is exactly the things
that marjorie taylor green did and i
would have wanted to hear more from the
petitioner about
on this date she did this and then on
this day she tweeted that and then she
met with the president and then you know
she so basically just step by step
that's just that that's that's what an
opening statement is supposed to be is
is you know kind of a a preview of what
the evidence is your story and you know
frankly he should know that this is
being uh televised on national
television practically you know all over
the world people are watching this tell
the story what are you going to show we
all know there was a violent attempt at
stopping the election and for a period
of time they did stop the peaceful
transfer of power so so we know that
that happened we know that there was you
know there's there's an insurrection
tell us what she did what was her
involvement talk about the facts you
know and and and the and again so i was
thinking that because the petitioner
stayed away from the facts i thought for
sure that the entire defense
opening was going to be you know you
didn't hear one single thing in their
opening about her being involved because
she wasn't involved
and these are the facts you know on from
my side you know she supports the
constitution she loves america she would
never do these things whatever whatever
their defense is going to be talk about
the facts and then i would go to and by
the way
uh
the law also doesn't support it but to
only talk about the law i they're both
clearly worried about the facts is the
bottom line because neither one of them
talked about it so do you think they're
playing a little bit close
to the chest because they feel like
anything bigger would be
a risk to make such like accusations if
if they feel like the evidence really
isn't there no i think what they i think
what's happening is because this is a
judge hearing and judges decide the law
they're focusing on the law and that's
that's really it but that's why the the
defense attorney is focusing on the
semantics of the and verses
trying to go with the apples oranges
comparisons
correct but the petitioner really
both both for the court of public
opinion and for this court should have
focused more on on the facts of what did
marjorie taylor green do and also the
fact again that they're starting with
this historical
um you know with with uh the historical
precedent this is an insurrection again
i wouldn't have called this as as my
first witness i would have called like
set the stage you know you you are the
plaintiff you are the petitioner you're
the prosecutor so to speak you're
telling the story you want to capture
the um the the court of public opinion
you want the judge and everyone to be on
your side and to be not looking at the
and versus the or and the comma and
whatever you want them
to to be like oh wow
this is bad look what she did is bad and
for you to find want me to find that she
wasn't involved and to focus on the
comma and the end versus or you got a
long you know a long road to you know
a lot a big hill to climb and and so far
the petitioner in my opinion has not
captured kind of the heart and soul of
the case or or the public opinion of the
case you know and they and they really
needed to
you know if you're a democrat if you're
a democrat you're against margie taylor
green but guess what 50 of the country
is is on her side
so you need to focus on you know and
everybody's watching this they really
need to focus on on what did she do and
they didn't
do you think uh madison cawthorne is
kind of watching this case closely
i think everybody's watching this case
closely don't you think well yeah i mean
specifically him because aren't the
constituents of his district uh also uh
coming at him with the 14th amendment to
to remove him from the ballot i know
that he was
complaining about that so yeah so he
there was a kid he brought it um
the same people who brought this case
against marjorie taylor green also um
also
are doing did the same thing with
madison cawthorne but uh you know but he
drew a different judge he drew a judge
that um is a trump supporter and um that
judge ruled the opposite of what the
judge uh in marjorie taylor green's case
um ruled which was
uh
it's sort of a legal technicality that
that the judge in that case said that
you know that that um
basically it that it only there's a
there's a statute
that um that that gave amnesty to
uh people in the civil war um you know
just to basically say you know what we
had a war but there's an amnesty that
says you you guys can run for office
you're not disqualified and so there was
this this amnesty act
and um this judge ruled that the
and that the amnesty act applies didn't
apply
to the past that it applied to the
future
and so therefore it doesn't apply to
madison cawthorne what the judge in the
marjorie taylor green case
judge totenberg said that's preposterous
of course you know that that amnesty act
applied retrospectively not
prospectively and and by the way the law
doesn't work that way you know there's a
hierarchy in the law and so the 14th
amendment is an amendment to the
constitution that that's a
constitutional right that trumps
everything that's the bedrock the
foundation of everything that we have
if congress passes a law
that comes net that that's sort of a
lower on the totem pole right the the
constitution it's like as as michael
popock my co-host on legal af said it's
like rock paper scissors right and one
trumps the other well the constitution
and the amendments to the constitution
trump the law if
or i should say um
congressionally passed uh laws and
statutes so if if congress wanted to do
something uh that that was going to
influence the 14th amendment to the
constitution they would have had to pass
a constitutional amendment hard to do
hasn't been done in a long long long
time certainly not in my lifetime
and uh you know so it's it's it doesn't
make any sense that that um
that cathorin you know that that corn um
you know
that the judge in that case ruled the
way they did but that's that's where
they are
yeah that's uh so i think i think it's
all good points um
you know madison cawthorne um you know
obviously
obviously an insurrection himself as
well you know if you if you're if this
court's gonna find that marjorie taylor
green and this judge is gonna find that
she is an insurrectionist and she's um
not qualified to be on the ballot um
then our assumption is that a lot of
these members of congress are not
qualified to be on ballots and i think i
think that's kind of the point here is
the po
the political point not the legal point
because i want to go back to that
because
we talked a couple times about what kind
of court this is because is this
actually a court or is this just a
hearing to figure out if she can be on a
ballot i mean what what is this
so this is an administrative hearing
and um it's it's a nuance i mean yes
this is a court but it's an
administrative court and this is this is
um
it's not a criminal court where somebody
where liberty is determined
and where you know somebody's convicted
of crime or anything like that is
determined and it's not a civil court
where um
where monetary damages are
are um
are
decided you know that's typically what
happens in in civil courts this is an
administrative court where they're
trying to decide whether under georgia
state law
administratively she can be put on a
ballot and whether the secretary of
state who has rule making authority over
the elections of the state of georgia
whether they
their rule making about what qualifies
someone to be on a ballot or not whether
she's qualified you know that there are
different you know that's why one of the
things the defense attorney was saying
was um
you know is this um is she qual a
qualified candidate you know hold on i
actually took notes let me find my my
notes about what exactly they were
saying um you know but he he was saying
is this a um
you know was this was this was she
qualified to be a candidate or qualif or
qualified was she not qualified to be a
candidate or not qualified to take
office i guess those are the two things
that in georgia the secretary of state
has authority over and he's saying this
is not whether she qualified to be a
candidate you know like i guess you have
to be a certain age or you know
all that kind of you have to be a united
states citizen perhaps or not have a
criminal record i don't know whatever
the georgia qualifications to be a
candidate or he's saying that's not
what's what what the issue is here she's
qualified to be a candidate she's been
qualified before to be a candidate what
she's saying is she qualified to take
office and that that's what this is
about and the petitioner didn't agree
that this is an administrative hearing
to determine that so
so um
so you know that's where
where we are um so really quick you um
you gave me permission to uh jump
whenever i had to i don't have to leave
but i do have to press pause and uh take
care of something for five minutes
that's fine
then i'll be back yeah let's let's do
that and uh because we're gonna me and
gable talk and then um we'll be right
back uh because we got the uh thing
going so we'll see here in just a minute
karen
okay so gabe um
it really it
it really is something to watch um the
theatrics here again karen alluded to it
that that government sometimes is is
really [ __ ] boring um especially when
you have moving right especially when
you have grandpa mothballs um trying to
make arguments right for
uh marjorie taylor green in a way that
would uh put my dog to sleep um
and call him
to the microphone yeah
you pointed out you pointed out hey are
you snoring or is your dog if if anyone
doesn't know who are new uh listeners
here to the tony michael's podcast um
sometimes sometimes my dog falls asleep
either on the chair in front of me or
beside me and if i'm not talking or if
there's not noise you can hear him
snoring so uh that's that's that's what
happens it looks like uh people are
gonna be uh working their way back into
the hearing room um so we'll we'll go
back to it as soon as they start up well
what what's your take on it so far as
far as your confidence
in that marjorie taylor green will not
appear on the ballot because they made a
case about the primary ballot which is
coming up right so that's that's what
everyone's trying to do is keep her off
the primary ballot and the reason why
you keep brought the primary about
because if she can't win the primary
she can't be in the general election
right yeah yeah so yeah you know i i
look at this and i think you know karen
made some good points um
and you know to reiterate those is like
we definitely saw you know the defense
was just arguing semantics right like
again obviously because this is like
what is the word of the law you know
uh he's gonna he's going to
argue
uh
you know the and or because it's like oh
well it's not or which means it could be
either or they're saying that it was and
which means that technically um marger
taylor green didn't
and he's not saying that she didn't do
both of them he's saying or rather one
or the other he's like she didn't do
both of them because that's the clause
that they're using right they're using
this and
instead of an
um
and
yeah i look at this and i'm like i
didn't see a lot of uh you know i didn't
see evidence from the defense which or
from the from the prosecution which i
was hoping for to get something right
like here's video or like there was
video of her there were phone records
right right right
geo tagged in his areas
but i also didn't see much from the
defense either the judge the judge is
chastising the uh the marjorie taylor
green fans now uh basically saying quit
your [ __ ] clapping um this is this is
a hearing room this is not a goddamn
concert
looks like we're gonna get back to uh
two more minutes
no further questions that's it
so in other words when he when he
started to ask the expert's opinion that
the judge stopped it because it's only
his opinion not fact is that right yeah
it seems like yeah
and i was a history major the judge see
the judge said sustained without defense
oh here we go
game time
so this is where this is where marjorie
taylor green as i call her marjorie hoof
foot green is going to take the stage
again
please
these are the media going to be the
words under scrutiny the most
um
you were elected to congress in november
of 2020 right
yes
and you became a member of congress on
january 3rd 2025 is that correct yes and
when you became a member of congress you
became a member of congress by virtue of
having taken them
off right
i became a member of congress by being
elected by the people of the 14th
district okay but you actually were
permitted to take your seat in the house
of representatives
because you took an oath of office isn't
that correct i swore and i was on
january 13th and that oath requires
difficult witness she won't even support
and defend the constitution of the
united states right
and it required you to swear note that
you would support and defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies right
yes
and part of the oath that you took
says that you were going to undertake
that
obligation to defend the constitution
against all enemies
freely
without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion you recall that
part
i think so okay well let's have a look
at this will be uh plaintiff's exhibit
63 i just want to make sure you get a
chance to escape
looks like we have an interruption in
the feed we're waiting for the video
signal to continue of course during the
um
testimony of martin j the green we have
a
a problem with the feed it's not on our
end it's not on youtube's end um looks
like it's just a technical difficulty
there in the room there we go
maybe
maybe i wish we could see what the
evidence was at the presenting yeah well
in perfect world you would um
i need multiple angles in this courtroom
tony
we need law and order angles right karen
is that what we need is we need a long
order angle exactly i need to close that
up over the shoulder i need to see
people in the in the dramatic pauses of
the judge the look of the of
of of course uh we're getting no video
feed now it might be because they're
trying to maybe they are trying to move
the camera is the reason why we lost
maybe maybe the maybe the russian
hackers or oh well there you go we're
really getting deep into conspiracy now
um
no no i do it this is no
it actually can be i mean you know it
could be the the the the trump support i
mean her supporters could have hacked in
and right
they pulled the plug
um it is a little weird that she took
the stand and she got one or two
questions answered and then
right we're now waiting for life i don't
know if you picked up on it that was
supposed to be an easy question you know
you you you were basically sworn in and
that's why you were a congress like that
was supposed to be like a kind of
softball right a golf ball like let's
get to the meat of this and she couldn't
even answer that
so it's going to be very interesting
she's going to be a tricky i really hope
this comes back because i this is going
to be she's going to be a tough witness
and this is where you need someone who
is a real seasoned litigator who can
control the courtroom control the
witness and ask the questions
uh if it doesn't come back i'm gonna go
to
uh c spanish
okay we have an alternative cheese
well uh c-span has a feed so we'll go to
c-span's feed if we can't uh get this
other sp feedback yeah i would say move
over
here
yeah let me let me switch it here real
quick
i'm looking forward to the law and order
episode where there's a technical
difficulty
there we go now we have a we have a
much better the constitution wouldn't
you agree
does it define that way
does it define that well i'm asking for
your understanding if somebody broke the
law
in a way designed to interfere with the
process of counting the electoral count
college votes
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution
you mean interrupting congress is that
what you're referring to
doing anything unlawfully to interfere
with the process of counting the
electoral votes
interrupting congress like when the
democrats she's not smart
on the house
i'm entitled to ask my questions in the
way i'd like to ask them your honor i
ask that you listen to my question and
simply respond
may i proceed
yes
so if someone broke the law
in an effort to interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution am i right about that
yes
breaking the law is unlawful there's
been over 700 people charged uh for what
happened on january 6th right and those
people were trying to interfere
with the lawful process of counting the
votes for the electoral college right
i i
i would assume yes they they did they
stopped the electoral count right and so
those people would be enemies of the
constitution you would agree with that
right
say it i don't know that i don't know i
don't know if it defines it that way
well
having taken the oath that we saw on the
screen
if you were aware that someone was going
to lost
do you think unlawfully they would be an
enemy with the constitutional process of
counting the electoral votes
you'd be obliged by your oath to try to
stop them right your honor i i object uh
the client the claim is not she violated
her own the claim is under section three
of the fourteenth amendment uh and so
her opinion is not a little comfortable
our words of art often in the law
is just irrelevant to uh to the matter
whether or not she engaged it did a
direct and uh
overt act uh of interrupt your honor we
we we had a one hour presentation on the
law from mr bob we did not object to
that
i will let you answer the question i
forgot what it is
can we ask for it to be right back
question if you were
aware that somebody was going to
unlawfully
interfere with the constitutional
process accounting electoral votes you
would be obliged
to have them arrested or stopped right
you may answer
you may answer the question to the best
of your bill
i had no knowledge
of any attempt and so that's a question
that i can't answer well
i can't answer that question i i i take
your representation that you had no
knowledge for the for the time being i'm
asking it as a hypothetical question
just to understand
your answer
well i'm permitted to ask you one so i'm
going to ask you again if you had
knowledge in advance that someone was
going to unlawfully interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes in a
presidential election
under your oath you'd be obliged to do
something to stop that right object
she's not being charged for violating
her
there's no
foundation laid that she had any
knowledge about anything like that we'll
come to that and so these
things
the objections show that that they're
nervous about this
different way on the screen
i mean really
yes and no they're just trying to
disrupt the narrative they're trying to
make the obligations because she doesn't
have to talk freely and without yeah
it's back and forth the judge and the
judge agreed from a few minutes ago
right the worst possible thing here
would be to get a free-flowing
you know yeah kind of thing the lawyer's
going to object objectives
and the
you knew that before you took the oath
and you took the oath anyway
and decided not to do anything
about those plans
that would be a mental reservation don't
you agree i've checked she's not she is
not being charged with violating the
elders
the question is she engage in
insurrection or rebellion
her state of mind is relevant your honor
we think it's very important to have her
understanding what
it's relevant to whether she engaged in
insurrection during the time period from
january 3rd to january 6th and we're
going to be talking about her state of
mind all day you may come back to that
question after you have laid a
foundation for why it ties into her
activities coming after the fair enough
fair enough drama
um ms greene you're familiar with social
media right
and that's a form of communication right
yeah you know what facebook is and
twitter right yeah you use those as an
important form of communication in your
work
yes you post messages on facebook right
when she's not banned yeah yeah she puts
statements messages yes videos also
right
yes
and you also
respond and react to other people's
comments when they're posted on facebook
or twitter right
yes
and you do that as a way to get your
political views out into the world
it's my freedom of speech to do so i
agree
um and you've been very successful at
using social media to get your your
views out of the world right
i would say that's an opinion well i'm
asking your opinion you've got
hundreds of thousands of people
who follow you
on twitter and facebook right
no not really because my twitter my
personal twitter account
doesn't exist anymore before it was
suspended by twitter
you had hundreds of thousands of people
following you on facebook and twitter
right yeah and by the way
the way facebook and twitter work is my
understanding is they don't have to
necessarily follow you
to read what you have to say right
i guess so so
it could be millions of people who have
read the things that you have said on
facebook and twitter over the years
i don't know that
but it could
he would agree with that right
no i don't know that i don't know how
many people read or see
what i post on social media
but what you post on social media is
what you want people to know about your
political that's factually incorrect you
can actually see the impressions of your
tweets you can actually see it
sure okay you're not putting stuff up
there as a joke are you
sometimes yes
um well we'll go we'll come back to that
and you use facebook and twitter to
to communicate with your constituents in
the 14th congressional district here in
georgia right yes
so
immediately after the 2020 election
and through january 6th and even beyond
that
um you issued a number of
tweets and made statements on twitter
and facebook
about the election right
yes you tweeted a whole lot of material
about your views of what happened in the
2020 election yes and
the thrust of those tweets
were that you felt that the election was
stolen from the sitting president i
object that is
you can ask the question what is your
opinion what is it well well i also want
to ask whether she communicated that
opinion through
well let's do it that way your honor i i
take your point
i'm going to show the witness a number
of her tweets and i wanted to make sure
that i understand the context of them
that's all
well she said she posts on twitter right
and my question is whether she posts
material that reflect the opinion that
you have strike that ms green you you
had you had the opinion between november
2020 when the election happened and
january 6
2021 that the election was stolen from
president trump
am i right about that
if you've got questions about specific
documents or specific things go ahead
let's not um
let's let's go to px2a as well please
i'm sorry which one is this
a 2a your honor
at least now we can kind of see what's
going on
no i'm not really see that
and um what we have here in
2a is a document um
well i'll ask you um can you tell us
is this a statement that you posted
on twitter
uh
on december 3rd 2020
yes ma'am
yes yeah and
this is a
statement where you talked about
um
that you were looking for a senator to
join yourself and representative mo
brooks to reject the fraudulent votes
for joe biden and to keep the real
donald trump in the white house right i
attract your honor to
the
you can hear my objection i'm waiting
i'm waiting with baited breath jen all
right
just violates the right of free speech
there's nothing in this statement that
meets the brand of her test even if
speech could be considered
since it can't when we're dealing with
uh he get engages which is conduct not
speak if it is free speech then why the
objection like if that's truly what it
is then why the objection if it is free
speech
why are you objecting fighting or
producing imminent flawless action your
honor we heard an hour of argument this
morning
try to see because the judge seems
frankly to be
i would say more on the marjorie taylor
green side than on the petitioner's side
i was just curious to see if i could
figure out who all i've all i've seen so
far is he was a tax lawyer for a hundred
years when you sent out this
strike that did you send out this tweet
it was green
as well could you put it back up
yes okay
and when you sent out this tweet you
wanted the people who the judge comes by
to know that it was your view
that
the votes from mr biden for president
were fraudulent or some of them were
right
that really wasn't the purpose of that
tweet
i'm just asking whether when you sent
this you were communicating some are
saying in the chat karen that
that this judge was appointed by
governor kemp i'm not sure if that's
true
for mr biden and that your goal was to
keep president trump in the white house
i was communicating that we were looking
for a senator to join our objection
which is very much
uh part of the
responsibilities and duties
that i can do as a member of congress i
agree with that
but the purpose of that
was because you believed
that the votes for mr biden were
fraudulent right
or at least some of them
we had we had been
spending a vast amount of time reading
she won't say yes
and have seen uh tremendous evidence of
voter fraud i don't know if you're aware
because i know so know then i guess
currently have our secretary of state
your honor i would hope to strike this
i'm entitled to get answers to my
questions your honor
thank you thank you
all right let's let's back up
by the way
your honor i'm sorry to interrupt we
missed something very important can the
representative be sworn oh thank you no
i swore oh you did oh okay i didn't see
that i'm sorry
sorry thank you all right
um
and can i ask the court to acknowledge
that this is a an adverse wisdom witness
a hostile witness
she has to answer my questions she can't
give speeches
is that fair
to require her to answer when the
question is objectionable violates the
first amendment right is irrelevant to
the charges that are uh being made uh
just to
what fishing expedition political
theater what is that this is this is
cross-examination she has a fifth
amendment right not a first amendment
right when she's under oath i i don't
understand what what's going on here
you have a standing objection mr bob
to everything in the world i want to
question your witness let her know
this is not theater
this is not an argument from the supreme
court this is an evidentiary hearing so
let's get going go ahead mr child
um ms wells can you pull up plaintiff's
exhibit
2c please
what was which
um we have a comment here that this is a
[ __ ] show and anything involving marjory
taylor green is definitely a [ __ ] show
in your account
on
december 19
2020
yes
and in this tweet um
let me go back a second your honor i
would just ask that
the previous exhibit which i think was
2db um admitted into evidence
22d
i'm sorry 2a all right so 2a is b
um i'd ask that 2c be admitted into
evidence
2c all right
say that again i was distracted
sure i asked the witness if this was her
tweet she said it was this is your tweet
okay
and i ask it to be admitted into
evidence i object that it's not
probative and it violates the first
amendment right well it's nothing to do
with engage it doesn't
originate
it's in for what it's worth
okay i mean i don't know
as i think everyone can see she really
hasn't answered a question yet
we've this is all about the lawyers the
judge and this is what right this is the
tactic it's a tactic
the tactic on whose part the defense
absolutely it depends
why would she take the stand then does
she have to here
one of the things you're communicating
to the people who
would read this tweet was that you want
them to come to washington
on january 6th
for a demonstration
is that right
for a march for trump right march
fight for trump
the phrase that you use there
is hashtag fight for trump right that's
what the words say that's what it says
on my tweet okay
um
oh she could tweet that day i posted
that because you in fact wanted people
to show up
on january 6
2021 in dc
in order to help you
stop
the theft of the 2020 election from your
point of view
now
okay
well i'm not sure we got a clear answer
on this you you did believe at this time
that the 2020 election had been stolen
by the democrats from mr trump right
i i was asking people to come for a
peaceful march which is
what everyone
is entitled to do
under their first amendment but i was
not asking them to actively engage in
violence or any type of action
that wasn't the question no it's really
simple it's about your opinion
when this tweet came out in this period
it was your opinion that the election
had been stolen from mr trump or was
about to be stolen right
under my opinion there was a tremendous
amount of
fraudulent
things that happen in the election
and under my opinion i want to do
anything i can to protect election
integrity and to protect
the
people of my district in georgia uh
people's votes they should count
anything she can
representative green that from election
night of 2020
until january 6 2021
your personal opinion and your wish
was that congress not certify
joe biden as the winner of the 2020
election
uh no that's not accurate
what
you believed that joe biden had lost the
election
she's under oath by the way i don't know
if that matters
well yes we saw a tremendous amount of
voter fraud we have uh investigations
going on right now remember she's under
oath when she's saying these things in
multiple states
my own husband showed up to vote on the
general election and when he went in to
vote in person he was told that he had
already voted by absentee ballot when in
fact he had never even requested an
absentee ballot these are facts that
could be dug up
oh
your
let me we could honor this now i
understand there's an i.t issue that
requires a pause okay well should we
take how long do we need
two minutes all right well i'm not sure
about
be patient
all right so she's she just claimed i
don't know if i've ever heard that
before that her husband
was a
victim
of this whole ballot issue
um which is interesting what do you
think about her being under oath garen
and making these claims
you know
so far she hasn't really answered the
question right so i
i
right now i i don't i think it's way too
soon to make any predictions about
being under oath and telling the truth
et cetera because
do you have a really answered a question
other than you know she's talked about
her husband's experience you know one an
anecdote
doesn't
make a trend and you know how many court
challenges have there been where they've
actually looked for
these these defects that they've been
talking about and every single one of
them has been thrown out i mean this
claim of you know dead people voting or
my husband showing up or all these all
these story you know these stories of
of you know the the election was stolen
not not one of them has has
come about with any kind of you know
none of them are true i mean every
they've every single one of them has
failed in court so yeah they've all
resulted in rudy giuliani leaking
leaking from his hair i mean that's kind
of the result of all these claims that
they made even in federal court rudy
giuliani had to say to the judge
in in not so many words we are not
claiming fraud like literally he had to
say that to the judge because from my
understanding he can't lie
in court
okay yeah i mean
i don't know that this is a good idea
for the uh for the plaintiffs because
now it gives marjorie taylor green uh an
opportunity to really
conference with her attorneys as opposed
to stay on the stand but yeah i mean
look they've had plenty of time to
prepare i don't think a few minutes is
gonna make a difference
i just think the tactic here is
disruption right the tactic here is
you blow up
what you don't want is a smooth case
coming in on the petitioner's side
because they have the burden of proof
and so if they can just present evidence
and present stuff and it all comes in
smoothly their burden becomes easier and
what they're doing here is disrupt
disrupt disrupt try to blow up the
proceeding any way you can and try to
disrupt any kind of evidence that comes
in
any you know like i said we've barely
heard her speak so far
why i mean
i mean that those are that is good
points because when she has spoke she
hasn't answered a question she's
really been
it
you know practiced
to deflect in other words well you know
look i
i'm from new york so you know forgive me
for the following statement but is this
like what is this faux demure kind of
you know
like
southern thing that she's trying to pull
off here you know like
well they are in georgia so you know
bless her heart bless her heart
he's a good christian woman you see that
cross on her neck right yeah but is that
does that really does that
is
it might it might be effective with this
judge um yeah i mean we know that it
seems that this judge through this
hearing has some sort of
uh bias it looks like they're gonna take
a longer break than just an id break
um so we're gonna keep an eye on the uh
the hearing room here as we as we do
commentary but
karen did you did you find out is this
judge
um
a a kemp appointed judge you know i i
i was trying to actually listen to the
proceeding
i'm clearly not very good at well
maybe we could get our executive
producer over there to uh what yeah what
is the name of uh what is the name of
the judge what is the name of the judge
his name is uh bo b-e-a-u-d-r-o-t
bowdro i'm not sure how you pronounce
that
dro probably something like that
charles r
bowdrow jr
he's a junior which makes it even more
sus no i'm just kidding i i mean i don't
i don't i don't know i um you know this
judge seems to um have a bias here but
really
you say it's an administrative court and
he is a judge but it and he's going to
hand down a ruling but it seems very
awkward it's almost like
it's almost like a city council type
meeting right like not really
you know what i mean it's not really
like a courtroom as in the civil or
criminal trial like you were saying
earlier it's more
like a city council or school board
meeting where they're going to vote to
have a certain policy in the school or
certain or they're going to put a stop
sign at this certain intersection i mean
i know that seems a little more
insignificant than what we're talking
about but really that's kind of the
proceeding here right am i am i wrong in
saying that no it's an administrative
hearing um yeah it's it's exactly right
it's exactly what you're what you're
saying and at the end he's gonna make a
ruling i think it's gonna i think
my prediction is he's going to say that
she stays on the ballot
she
he's not going to disqualify her
why do you why do you say that is it
based on the evidence that we've seen or
are just because of what we haven't seen
yet
neither i think it's such a significant
to to basically deprive you know
elections democracy voting i mean these
are
fundamental bedrocks of our society and
this little administrative judge i don't
think he's going to make that
god forbid he gets it wrong right you
know he's not going to
he i think he'd rather sort of let it go
forward see if she wins see you know
because look let's say he lets it go
forward and she loses
then
you know then you don't have to even get
to these questions right or but so see
if she wins if she wins if she gets
elected and maybe and i think he's going
to say this isn't a thing for congress
you know because again
even if you show
that um there was an insurrection that
day and even if you show that that she
said what she said what what is the
standard of finding that she
was a part of the insurrection you know
it's i just think it's legally it's a
little um i think it's a little
complicated and a little uh dramatic
frankly i just don't see him
and he also seems slightly biased you
know i i hate to say it or maybe more
than slightly i don't know but it so far
he seems a little um
a little more more biased so i i think
he's going to
uh frankly kick it over to congress and
let congress uh make this make this
decision or or a federal court um once
she's elected i don't see in it because
i think at the end of the day he is
gonna say this is a little
administrative hearing and you know yet
we're making a decision about a
constitutional issue
and i think he's not gonna i just don't
think he's gonna do it i don't know i
don't know exactly how he's gonna
shoehorn his decision into that you know
it could look like a bunch of different
things but i think that's going to be
the ultimate result
um
unfortunately which i i know is is going
to be disappointing to a lot of people
uh when it happens but i i don't just
even the way it's going so far nothing
has come in
at all remotely
for the petitioners to hang their hat on
nothing and for him to even make a
decision for him to even make a decision
because we are talking about the primary
ballot at this point yeah that's that's
the decision that this judge is making i
want everyone to make that clear that
this isn't for the general election
ballot that's going to happen in
november for the 2022 midterm they are
specifically talking about and you've
seen in the beginning um they're talking
about the the uh primary that is about
to happen in may so just just within
a few weeks from now yeah i mean the
ballot's already printed as somebody
pointed out no there's so there's no way
he's going to
disrupt that i think he's just going to
allow
democracy and the constitution to
proceed and
and let congress decide whether to swear
her in or not and at the end of the day
that that's
that's where i see this is happening
hmm
so i i haven't seen anything that
definitively says that kemp was an
appointed i did i was able to look up
the kent appointed judges
uh i don't know if these are like brand
new judges that are put to different
different seats but everything that is
seen in the local level and other state
courts court of appeals and the supreme
court
uh
neither of which mention the name i do
know that from what i've seen
uh the honorable charles r boudreau jr
was appointed to the georgia tax
tribunal by governor
nathan
diehl which is the former
georgia governor and he was appointed in
november of 2012 to the georgia tax
tribunal so i don't know at what point
he shifted over but from what i see i
mean unless someone can find something
differently but i'm not finding anything
on balapedia or anywhere else that says
that kemp was the one who actually moved
him over
it also could have been done
but i'm not seeing any official
documentation that says kemp was the one
who did it
so so this guy was an administrative
judge in a tax court is that kind of
yeah same taxes
just in a
okay tax trade it must be that must be a
georgia thing i mean i'm sure but at
least have a tax return
so i don't
uh i don't know i mean i can tell you
where he went to school i can tell you
his uh previous uh law firm that he was
at what's here let's hear the uh the
school that he went to why not we might
as well
well he went to um
oh not gonna log in oh wow i believe
what i saw earlier uh hold on researcher
we got here karen i'll tell you what no
i was trying i'm actually impressed
i was trying to do things
he's pretty good at researching uh on
the fly but usually he has a link or
something for me that i can throw you
know i don't know right right right yeah
hold on okay so
let me go
let me get back to this
uh our boy charles r boudreau he's a
composer and musician
oh he was an administrative law judge
and a retired lawyer from morris manning
and martin llp
um
yeah he is from 2013 so i'm assuming
that this is still part of the deal kind
of appointment but it says he served as
a judge at the office of this state
administrative hearings osa at the state
of georgia
and he's been that we've been an
administrative judge for a long time
he's been this way since january 2013.
so what i think happened is he he was
tax tribunal judge and then that was in
november of 2012 and then shortly
thereafter within a few months he
shifted over to this uh administrative
hearings
judge
but he previously um
went to harvard got his jd
went to duke he got his ba in history
um
yeah well that's why that's why he
wasn't having it when when the plaintiff
or the petitioner tried to put on a
history
expert like uh you know
i know about history i don't i don't
need a history you know he don't need to
be taught in other words yeah yeah i
mean
1969-1973 those were the well and then
1973 to 1976 but those are the times
that he was in school
i mean look taking off sort of the hat
of what do we want to have happen and
who do we like better and and what we
think
uh we want here i i have to say
i i do think that um to ask an
administrative judge in an
administrative hearing
um to take the extraordinary step of
saying somebody is not qualified to be
uh on the primary ballot in a couple of
weeks
when she hasn't been charged convicted
convicted or in any way held accountable
being an insurrectionist i think is is a
really extraordinary step that that he's
being asked to do and i just don't see
him
uh thinking that it's the appropriate
forum to do it and
and you know it's there there will be
other opportunities to to challenge this
in in probably uh federal court or in
congress which is i i think it's a
slightly more appropriate potentially
more appropriate and legitimate place to
make a constitutional
uh challenge the way um the way that
he's being asked to do here that that's
that's what i think um this feels like
and seems like just just from from
watching this
well so you're so in other words you're
go you're saying that it may be easy for
him to kick the can down the road so
that may be the avenue he takes because
it does make sense for him to say hey
this is a constitutional issue this
isn't an administrative issue is that
kind of the can that you're saying he
might kick because it's easy to kick yes
okay
well and and having think about it what
if he gets it wrong
what if he says uh what what if he says
you know you're not qualified and then
that's obviously going to and then she's
not on the ballot
and she doesn't get elected and then
it's it's going to be challenged in
court and what if he got it wrong what
do you do then you can't then
kind of
you know it's much easier to get someone
elected and then
take them off you know basically
disqualify them and hold a special
election than it is to not let someone
go forward and be elected and then oops
we made a mistake here you can't then
hold you know you're not going to hold
the special election that way so
i just you know
i don't know i i just think that that
from uh
again it's it's their constitutional
rights and their constitutional rights
right
and the the the bedrock of our democracy
is about the right to vote and um
i just don't see a
administrative hearing where people are
are clapping and and the plaintiff
didn't talk about any facts
and
you know or the petitioner i keep
calling them the plaintiff but um you
know i don't know i just don't see this
this is not the major leagues that's
happening here in any way not on either
side you know we're not watching a
well-oiled machine um we're watching a a
very local
which is very real right this
this is what most courtrooms are like
it's a very local sort of you know
technical difficulties with people
shouting in the audience we have you
know lawyers who are are
very good but they're not you know these
these celebrities show show men and
women um and you got an administrative
judge i just don't think he's going to
to make a decision that that um
i i just don't think he's going to make
a decision that that goes to the
fundamental heart of who we are as a
society
in this particular you know we're we're
basically in traffic court you know like
right right
so it's just i just don't see it
happening and i think um i could be
wrong i hope i'm wrong but i just i
don't see it happening i think this goes
to
so outside the legal ramifications
because there are political
ramifications of this as well i mean
marjorie taylor green actually happened
to take the stand and actually having to
answer some of these questions could
have political ramifications right it
could it could hurt her in her politics
um to to run in an election so i'm not
saying that that is the intention here
that's what i'm saying um but i i i am i
am trying to point out that just because
that the decision that is made by this
administrative judge rather it is the
decision you want or not i'm talking to
the listeners if it is a decision that
you
desire in this uh in this situation or
not
i i believe that there are going to be
political consequences for marjorie
taylor greene taking the stand which it
sounds like she has to do um and
answering but more importantly not
answering some of these questions
because
almost at the fundamental core of
marjorie taylor green's personality
because that's truly what she is she's
not she's not a real congress person to
a degree that she sits on committees
she doesn't have the ability to
interject in committees so
she is only only a personality that can
go to the floor during debate
and create social media moments on video
that she can retweet and i want to be
clear she said during her and this is
one of the political ramification i
think is very bad for her she continues
to talk about how she's banned from
twitter and she is not that is a lie and
the other thing that's a lie that she
said is that you can't you can't figure
out how many people see your tweets
that's also a lie she might not i mean
i'm not trying to defend her she might
not know i mean like i'm on twitter and
i have no idea well right right
fair enough fair enough fair enough tell
me what what do you mean by the fact
that she's not banned from twitter why
would she say that she's clearly talking
about something
so she has two accounts on twitter her
personal account
was banned a permaban she'd been
suspended several times and twitter had
cut off her permanent account but
because she's a member of congress she
has afforded an official congressional
account um that is that is verified it
is going to be archived as as a public
official and she still tweets from that
account so the idea that she absolutely
is not on twitter is a bold-faced lie so
that's so that's a point that her that
the petitioner's lawyer
if you if
you know again not to monday morning
quarterback because it's hard to be no
please do please do please
i i want to go with the caveat that
being a trial
room being a courtroom lawyer is one of
the hardest things you can do right um
and but one of the things that they
should have said when she said that
would have been exactly what you just
said when she because she i was left
with the impression that she was banned
from twitter right and right and so what
the lawyer what the petitioner should
have done at that moment is said
isn't it true
so
so miss
miss green are you're saying that you're
banned from twitter right so you're
saying you have no ability to tweet at
all is that what you're saying
yes so but isn't it true that as a
member of congress
you are afforded at whatever you know
her actual twitter handle is and you
know and and so so and you have control
over that and you can tweet from that
and blah blah you know on and on and
just show right there through those
questions you are a liar you don't have
to call her a liar you don't have to say
i mean i can't i can but yeah well the
other thing the ineffective litigator
that's what you do show that she's
that's an easy thing right like that's
you're not going to get her to agree
with your opinion this was an
insurrection or this was not an
insurrection but show her to be a liar
again you you want and and does it and
and what significance does that mean
that she's a liar the more times you can
do that all of a sudden the judge might
start might kind of say you know what
i'm not going to believe this if she
lies about these simple things i don't
know that i'm going to believe her with
these other things and same thing in the
court of public opinion again
i think i pay pretty good attention to
things i had no idea that she has the
congressional twitter account again i
was left with the impression
that she's banned from twitter the way
so many people who should be banned are
banned but i again this was an easy this
is an easy ground ball missed
opportunity
from the petitioner's side and and i
hate that i'm monday morning
quarterbacking or commenting on an
attorney because i would hate for
someone to do it to me
um it's a hard thing to do i've made a
million mistakes and will continue to
make mistakes it's hard to do it in
court but that's just you know that's
just a point that i want to make
right yeah the other the other thing too
is uh you know
the
the plaintiff was uh making the argument
to say like okay you you send these
tweets out and they are visible to
hundreds of thousands of people right
and her claim is
well
you know not anymore because i don't
have my personal account right and
that's where you would go back and say
okay well which one was banned you still
have one account
but the other thing too is
easily verifiable is you just go to
you know rep mtg and you look on twitter
and you see that she's got over 500 000
followers right so you look at these
things and you're like there is the num
like no one can [ __ ] this number no
one can [ __ ] the fact that you have
two accounts one was permaband that you
have hundreds of thousands of followers
you have potentially over a million if
you were to combine both
of those
those channels
um
and then you know i think pushing that
forward for the argument which was
you know anyone on the platform can see
your tweets who are not even logged in
you know they can be embedded they can
be shared they can be screenshotted they
could be all of these things and saying
to the point of your words
have consequences and when your words
say we should
you know
block the certification or we should
fight it or whatever it's not just a
means of like
oh um i want to rally the troops but
there's more intent and more kind of
uh
malicious intent i'll say behind those
things and i think if you know to your
point it's like well if she says this
then refute it with well you have
another account if she says this then
repeat it with you've got over 500 000
people that follow follow you
specifically that doesn't include the
millions of people who are able to view
the tweets on a public
um kind of scale so
yeah i'm i
when this was brought up you know for
the same reason of like
she's
not answering a yes or no question and
saying like well i don't know or this or
that i think there are easy ways to get
around that and then rephrase the
question like you even saying like
what's your opinion do you think right
like let's work outside this world of
hypotheticals
or you know are are you as an
insurrectionist doing this but like do
you think that this is legal right well
what you just said though
so so there's a line of questioning that
you could ask
that you don't care what the answer is
because you're getting your story out
she could say no to all of those things
and again the petitioner could have said
isn't it true that on twitter there are
people who can watch you or not watch
you or whatever you know yes and she'll
say no or i don't know and isn't it true
that that
you know they'll see all the things that
you just said i don't know and isn't it
true then that it's possible that
millions and millions of people saw when
you said
that you know the election was a fraud i
have no idea who cares what her answer
is you know you're trying to get in
you're paying a picture for that for the
beginning
of the questions right for the judge
who's going to make this decision
because ultimately not only are you
painting a picture for him but you're
painting a picture politically uh
because the other the other thing that
that i find ridiculous is that she
doesn't know how many impressions she
gets and that's that's absolutely crazy
to me she's on she and
let's skip past twitter because she's on
facebook she's on uh telegram she's on
parlor she's on several other social
media platforms that has hundreds and
hundreds of thousands
of of uh
followers and those accounts are public
too anyone can go create an account and
go see those quote unquote tweets or
what her word is or what she's trying to
say in public um the the fact the fact
that she's blatantly lying on the stand
and and it's not really lying she's
stuck in this political mind right like
she's trying to get out into the
microphone that i was banned from
twitter like she wears it as a badge she
intentionally did that she intentionally
got banned but that's why again the
petitioner could have said right
isn't it true you're on facebook isn't
it true you're on your way isn't it you
know all those again who cares what the
answer is right so you're saying that at
you know mtg blah blah blah i mean you
know again you can just set the stage of
a that she's a liar and b get your story
out to your questions and so that's one
of the things her her lawyers being i
have to say effective at is he's
he is trying to prevent the petitioner
from telling their story through their
questions right and so he's interrupting
and disrupting and you know look the
petitioner's lawyer is is human and you
get flustered i mean i get flustered you
know in court sometimes you know not as
much anymore because i'm i'm older but
you know when i was when i was coming up
you know you you get people to object
object object object and you get the
judge and all of a sudden you don't
remember what's going on and then you
start to feel
you know a little bit insecure
and you know you're just throwing off
your game a little bit you know and and
it's hard it's a hard job to do and
and um and this defense attorney you
know or or whatever he is again i have
no idea if it's petitioner and
respondent or plaintiff and defense like
i have no idea what the parties are
called but you know i'm calling them
the defense
so
well it's definitely you know
yeah they're it looks like they're
coming back in but i was going to say
yeah like just like in sports you know
you're what you're talking about just
icing your opponent you're like yeah oh
we're gonna time out right before the
field go kick you know like stuff like
that that's how it's clearly happening
and i have to say it's effective
yeah i appreciate everybody here we go
again they're claiming technology uh uh
difficulties but this is the other
things too
margery to the green is the first
sitting uh
representative senator congress person
that has to testify to january 6. wow
okay well
as well
ms green this is a tweet that we talked
about a little bit earlier just a quick
question on it um
you issued this on
december 19 2020
correct i can't see real well but i
think that's the date maybe maybe we can
make it a little larger
that's what it says
and what you were doing in this uh tweet
was you were
tweeting out a story
uh from the epic times
uh about president trump saying that the
protests that were planned for january
6th were going to be quote wild right
for those who don't know this this epic
times is
a very evil right there under the
picture
fascist lying rag
it says trump trump calling supporters
should join wild protest in dc on jan 6.
okay i was throwing my objective i can't
see that i can't could you make a little
larger miss boss
you can answer the question
representative green what was your
question my question is what you were
doing in the tweet is you were tweeting
out a story
from the epic times
about president trump making a statement
that the protest on january 6th
would be wild
right
i tweeted an article that had the
details of the dates and times right and
also included president trump's
statements that he expected the
demonstrations on january 6 to be wild
right
i don't think that's what my tweet was
about okay well but you see that the
article says trump colin supporters
should join quote wild protests in dc
on jan
6. i don't remember tweeting that
specifically for what you're saying
those are your words
no
i'm actually reading from what's on
you're speculating on why i tweeted that
but i don't remember tweeting it for
that specific reason is green i'm just
asking questions i'm just answering
no you're not and
in your tweet you mentioned earlier that
um
your words join
march for trump and dc on january 6 to
fight for trump that you were urging
people to come to washington for a
peaceful demonstration right
peaceful demonstration right absolutely
yeah that word peaceful is nowhere in
this tweet right
have a look that word peaceful is not in
the street there's only half of it there
let's let's get give the representative
a paper copy of that one
i just want to make sure
um
well you know like is the word peaceful
in there miss green it does not say
peaceful my question you're asking me
and i said for peaceful
demonstrations this is a little more of
the lines of the question we were
talking about earlier i i'm asking
you didn't there's not a secret code in
there that's supposed to be peaceful
right well i never mean anything for
violence i don't support violence of any
kind and i've said it over and over
again so i i'm telling you you just do i
can find a tweet that goes against that
i never mean anything for violence
or a picture of violence we'll examine
that question go to planets exhibit two
f please
two
f f and frying yes
and
i'm looking at
um yes this top half of the exhibit
ms green this is a tweet that you sent
out
on january 2nd 2021 correct
i'm not sure
okay you don't recall this
i i don't recall tweeting that no okay
set that to one side
well let me ask this question
does anybody
tweet things on your twitter account
it's like that did anybody in january of
2021 tweet things on your twitter
account without your permission
on what day
anytime from
november of 2020 to january 6th
i don't remember that's difficult the
answer okay which you'd be surprised if
somebody got into your twitter account
and tweeted something without your
permission wouldn't you
well no one tweeted anything without my
permission i just don't remember
who tweeted what
fair enough
follow-up follow-up follow-up
would you agree miss green that
this tweet
from january 2nd 2021
is something that we can fairly
attribute to you being that it was
tweeted on your twitter account
i
i'm sorry i
i don't know
okay
you take that down
um
the screen you've had your disagreements
with speaker pelosi isn't that right
i'm not sure what you mean you have
political disagreements with her you
don't agree with some of the things
she's done in her career right
politically speaking that would be
correct right you don't agree with a lot
of things she's done right
politically speaking that would be
correct in fact you think that speaker
pelosi is a traitor to the country right
looks over to the lawyer
i'm not answering that question of
speculation
you've said that have you on the screen
yep there it is there it is i haven't
said that okay
put up parents exhibit five please okay
i was like oh no
oh wait oh now i remember
by not upholding the uh securing the
border
that that violates
her oath of office
fair enough i'm i'm not interested in
her oath of office i'm interested in
that you said
that she's a traitor to our country
right
actually uh this is i don't see the
relevance of that mr chilly
your honor can we give mr bap a standing
objection on the first amendment grounds
because this is this is this is an
effort to interrupt my examination of
the witness
i am attempting to establish the
the
the witnesses of the judge's desire
to engage in insurrection
during the period january 3rd to january
6th now it's true that some of the
things that she said are relevant if
they were even though they occurred
before january 3rd but there's no first
amendment objection to evidence your
honor she's she said what she said
there is
you can make the objection you can have
a standing objection
because he wants to interrupt my flow
right that's that's not appropriate i
don't reject everything okay okay i have
specific things that i think i object to
and i i
should be extended the courtesy to do
that you may you may have checked
i'll plant some good five please well
five now
okay
um
so i'm placing before you um what we
pre-marked with plaintiff's exhibit five
which is an article that appeared in cnn
on january 26
2021
should be in the book
i mean did she have a hard copy i mean
she can't read it off the screen um
we have one for her
let's start using hard copies you can't
read stuff like this on the screen may i
approach the witness yes
you have standing permission approach
witness to deliver copies of documents
as to which you can ask your question
thank
you um as well as if you could scroll
down a bit
so
ms green i want to um direct your
attention to the bottom of
the fourth page of the exhibit
this is this is a paragraph that starts
out she's a traitor to our country do
you see that
i actually honor what possible relevance
could it be
that they she had political
disagreements that resulted in hyperbole
that is commonly used
this is
i just want to ask a narrow question
representative greene
um
did you say
referring to speaker pelosi
she's a traitor to our country
she's guilty of treason she took an oath
to protect the american citizens
she gives aid and comfort to our enemies
who illegally invade our land that's
what treason is
and our law representatives and senators
can be kicked out and no longer serve in
our government
and it's
a crime punishable by death is what
treason is nancy pelosi is guilty of
treason did you say those words
i said this is what i was telling you is
that i she doesn't uphold our laws uh
it's a simple yes or no question ma'am
did you say those words
without being instructed by him to say
yes or no i don't agree your honor this
is cross-examination she's entitled to
an answer to my question not a speech
did you say these words that are quoted
on the bible did you say that
according to the cnn article i did i
don't remember you recall today i don't
recall saying all of this but i do i do
recall having said this about the
i totally disagree with the border
issues
next question okay
um
and representative green you you have
advocated the use of physical violence
against people you disagree with
politically right i object without
contacts without uh anything
uh
for anyone watching the screen here um
you can see
you've advocated the use of physical
violence i put up a facebook post where
she was inciting violence that was that
and it was actually taken down by
facebook
i don't think so i don't know how to
answer that next question well um have a
look at what we've marked as planets
exhibit
five
e5 t5
that's the same
same one
right
you've got a copy of this representative
oh is it the same
okay
and
well let me ask a foundational question
um
you understand that
on social media posts like facebook and
twitter
uh one of the things well i guess on
facebook one of the things you can do is
you can like someone's post right
you can like people's
posts right
and when you like someone's post here's
one of the facebook posts that she got
pulled down for
from facebook correct that the post is
on the screen right
uh i don't know i don't agree with your
phrase or questioning well i'm asking
you
isn't it true that when you like when
you personally miss green like someone's
post you're signifying your approval for
what the post said no i don't agree with
how you're praising that question no i
don't agree with that
um so
it's true though that you liked a post
that suggested that quote a bullet to
the head of
nancy pelosi would be a quicker way to
remove her as speaker ouch ouch
you're using a cnn article which has
lots cnn has lied about me multiple
times and you're using a
cnn i'm asking you to answer my question
did you like a post
that said it's quicker that a bullet to
the head would be a certain way to
remove nancy pelosi from the role of
speaker had many people manage my social
media account over the years i have no
idea who likes that okay
you're are you testifying under oath it
wasn't you so the answer is yes it was
like testifying i have no idea who liked
that comment fair enough it could have
been you
right
go ahead next question
by the way you know miss green that
one of the places inside the united
states capitol building
that was invaded by people who were
doing violence was miss pelosi's office
right
i was inside the chamber
during uh on january 6th so i do not
know all the places that those people
went i only know where i was
are you telling us that in the
more than a year since these events
occurred
you have not become aware that one of
the offices that was invaded by people
who were illegally in the capital
was nancy pelosi's office i've seen that
on the news okay
but i don't know for sure i haven't i
haven't investigated all of that
now you mentioned earlier in response to
some of my questions that there was a
demonstration
that was being planned for
uh january 6 2021 called the march for
trump right
we talked about it on one of my twitter
posts right and and that demonstration
was being organized in part by an
organization called women for america
right
i don't remember who organized it okay
um
can you pull up um plaintiff's exhibit
2d
i'm sorry
is
i placed in front of you what's a
document that's been pre-marked as
planets exhibit 2d
um
you just begin by asking um
one of the things that you can do on
twitter
ms green is you can retweet or send out
again
somebody else's tweet right yes okay
and
on plaintiffs2d
which i placed in front of you you are
retweeting a tweet
sent by kylie jane cremer
on december 19 2020 right
i don't know if i retweeted it
well if you look carefully it says
marjorie taylor green has an american
flag and it says reach retweet it
i retweeted it you know you don't recall
one way or the other i don't recall
and it's your testimony that if this got
retweeted from your account that would
have been done with your permission
right
i don't i don't recall retweeting it
for those out there kylie kramer is the
one who bought the burner phones for
eric trump
kylie and uh and others on generously
retweeted from your account
in the form set forth as plaintiffs 2d
in
on december 20th
2012. i'm sorry december 19th
you don't deny that do you
this is what your picture has this paper
has i don't have this twitter account
anymore
so i don't recall i don't remember which
way she did have it then she did have it
there was this thing called the march
for trump it was going to be on january
6th right
yes and that women for america were body
organizers right
i don't remember but that's what this
says
okay
um
and one of the other
hashtags
for
the demonstrations that were planned on
january 6th
she's looking over to where in
washington dc
um was a hashtag um stop the steal
hashtag stop this deal right
yes yes
and
another hashtag that got used at the
time
was or i'm sorry a website that was
being used to organize people to come to
washington was something called
wildprotest.com
right
i don't know okay
px33xpxp
sorry
i placed
before you miss green
a document that was marked as
plaintiff's exhibit or petitioners
exhibit 33.
let me just ask a couple questions about
it
does this refresh your recollection that
there was a website known as
wildprotest.com
that was
encouraging people to come to washington
for a process a protest on january 6th i
don't remember the website but i'm
seeing it here on this
on your
paper okay
and
wild was the term that president trump
used to describe what he thought was
going to happen on january 6th right
wild is also a term that high schoolers
use when they talk about spring break
fair enough
um
but
whatever the
title of the demonstration or the name
or the hashtag that was used you would
agree that you were aware
in
after the election and before january 6
that people were being asked to come to
dc
for a large demonstration to object to
the certification of joe biden as
president of the united states right i
was aware people were coming to support
our objection in congress that on
january 6. the only thing i was
preparing for was objecting
when when did you first become aware
that there were going to be large
demonstrations in dc on the 6th
i don't recall
did you consider at any point
participating in any of those
demonstrations
it was put on my calendar but then i
never went if we were too busy we were
you know looking at all the evidence and
preparing for our debates and preparing
to object and preparing for an
insurrection i don't know
somebody on your staff i take it
i have no idea we have border phones to
buy you know stranger right it was
somebody from your congressional staff
right
bombs to plant maybe i mean allegedly as
you sit here
can you tell us
why it is that
a an appearance for you at that
demonstration was placed on your
calendar
can you rephrase that question how did
it come to pass that
it was put on your calendar that you
were going to appear at a demonstration
i understand you said you were too busy
i don't know i was so busy just
preparing to object i don't know
um you were going to
go to one of these demonstrations as a
speaker right
i don't think so i was always preparing
to object we were very busy well have a
look at what we've marked as
remember 33.
if you go about
three pages in at the bottom of that
page and then over to the next page
it says invited speakers and featured
guests right
i'm assuming i guess i was on there
because i was invited right but i don't
i don't know who made this website i i'm
sorry i can't answer okay well if you
say anything about it
well you can answer that that's your
name and face right
that is my name and face but i again i
don't run that website i have no idea
who does
my question to you representative greene
is
did some you or someone under your
authority at your congressional office
authorize
you to be placed as a speaker or guest
of the wild protest demonstration i get
many invitations as a member of congress
to many events and and all kinds of
speaking engagements and like a nickname
those go on my calendar but they have no
relevance as to whether i attend or not
so would it be fair to say ms greene
that through your office
you authorized your name
and your
likeness to be associated with the
wildprotest.com
demonstration no you cannot say that or
assume that
that would be whoever organized this
let's talk about that
going back to 33.
you know aly alexander don't you no i
don't really know
when you say you don't really know him
you've met him right
i've seen him before but i don't know
him i
yeah how many times have you been in his
physical presence to your knowledge i
cannot even guess hardly any
10
20 no
have you shaken his hand
i've shaken his hand before yes i shake
hands with
pretty much everyone i need lots of
people right um
and he's a friend of yours right now
okay
oh
not a friend
um
did you discuss with
mr alexander
the idea of you coming to appear at a
demonstration on january 6th i do not
recall that now you're not denying that
happening you just don't recall one way
or the other i do not recall that now
um
well did you discuss with anybody
attending the wild protest demonstration
that was planned for january 6th i do
not recall ever talking about attending
other than people
on your
congressional staff or your campaign
staff
list for me all the people who you spoke
to
about the demonstrations on january 6th
i i'm sorry i have no idea
okay you don't remember any of them i do
not remember not any of them no okay
and
you spoke to some people about those
demonstrations prior to being sworn in
as a representative from the 14th
district right
i i don't remember and you spoke to some
of those people
after you took the oath on january 3rd
and before the 6th right i don't
remember
um did you speak to anybody in
government
about the fact that there were going to
be demonstrations in washington on
january 6th
i don't remember we were mostly reading
information about election fraud and
people signed uh affidavits about what
they'd witnessed with voter fraud and
preparing to object that was pretty much
all i remember doing
pretty much but your testimony as you
sit here today under oath is that you
didn't talk to anybody in government
about the fact that there were going to
be large protests in washington
on january 6th i don't remember
just fyi i don't recall or i don't
remember is the sure way not to get hard
for perjury this is what this is she's
making it but she never gets charged
with perjury i do not remember
how about representative gosar
i'm sorry i don't remember so in other
words she does remember she does know
talk to people but she doesn't want to
be charged with birth we're going to be
large demonstrations on january 6th in
washington i don't remember
either that or she has dementia i mean
come on
right
it's a heartbreak january it's very
difficult to not remember all of this
anyone ever mentioned to you it's all
that crossfit that you know gets to your
memory maybe violence
in washington on january 6 2021. i don't
remember
so it's possible that folks told you
things could get violent in washington
on january 6th right can this judge the
judge knows this obviously i don't
remember those conversations and this is
what we were talking about earlier is
let her not actually answer but
my question is just about
whether anybody
at all ever mentioned to you the
possibility of violence i don't remember
okay so you're not denying it you're
just saying you don't recall i don't
recall
and
you don't recall that
people said
you know we're having these big
demonstrations in washington
and some of the people who come to those
demonstrations
might become violent
that never happened
the only violence i'd ever seen was the
antifa and blm riots and i've been to so
many trump rallies
remember that
yeah yep i don't recall and that was
before january 6.
i don't ever recall trump telling people
to take physical assault to others
those were trump people right
i knew there were many people coming to
support president trump and our
objection on january 6th right and
at least some of them were coming she's
practiced that line several times
i didn't purchase i don't recall
personally asking people to come but
evidently i tweeted about
uh january 6.
did anybody
strike that
did you have any conversations with
anybody
in government representatives
senators
white house staff the president united
states at the time
any government official or government
employee about the fact
this is now prior to january 6
about the fact that there was a risk
that people coming to washington for
january 6 demonstrations might become
violent i object that's the fourth time
he's asked the same question
really is the same question
what do you ask questions last time
i don't i don't recall
miss green did you ever hear that um
from any source prior to january 6 that
some folks were planning to come
to washington on january 6th and the
idea was that they were going to flood
the capital with people
no i don't remember ever hearing that
you never discussed that with anybody
no i do not remember that
um
but you supported the idea of people
coming to washington on january 6th
and flooding the capital right
no i support people's first amendment
to have a peaceful protest use their
freedom of speech well previously you've
publicly said
that one way for people to express their
displeasure with their government would
be to flood the capitol building with
people right that is true there's video
capital belongs to the people they
that's where you come and speak to your
uh senators your representatives
you you come to express your views you
come to talk about how you want your tax
dollars spent you come to talk about
how you want senators or representatives
to vote
my question is a bit more narrow than
that in 2019 she did say publicly
expressed support for the idea
that people should come to washington to
express their displeasure with their
government
by flooding the capitol
move on um can we have um please show
the video 23 please show the video
it's the one where she appears to be in
a hotel room with a black hat on right
there's
23 which is a
there's no way they can't play this
video this is the cnn article i believe
that you sent me um yep in in 2019
marjory taylor green told protesters to
flood the capital and feel free to use
violence
here we go they're objecting because
they're gonna they're they're gonna show
the proof that she just purges back high
school
uh they have to be treated with
statements that like fled the capital
flood the capital you're honored
it's not appropriate go ahead
you might you if you can figure out how
you're going to lay the foundation for
this you might proceed with mr thank you
um
i want to direct your attention
representative green to the second page
of this exhibit
shelby could you could you please go
through the proper things
so she knows what she's looking at
yes
i thought i did but i didn't hear it i'm
sorry okay
mrs green this is an article that
appeared
we believe in
on cnn
in the wake of january 6th i ask if
you've seen this document before
um no i haven't seen it
i can't remember all the rants i do
um
to be fair i don't remember the one i
did yesterday i mean to be fair well i'm
gonna it was two hours
you weren't telling people to flood the
capitol so that's true well tell me
whether you made them or not okay
the second page of the document
has a quotation that reads quote
all of us together when we rise up we
can end all of this we can end it
we can do it peacefully we can i hope we
don't have to do it the other way i hope
not
but we should feel like we will if we
have to
because we are the american people do
you recall making that statement
in 2019
in connection with a protest around
fund the wall
you're not denying it you just don't
recall
like everything else she said she does
not recall that is the answer let's move
on
if someone says i can't recall then i
would follow up and be like does this
refresh your memory and then play the
actual video right play the video with
your words like one thing to see print a
photo of the video and printed text but
it's another to actually see her say the
words right which i hope to god they're
going to do
i mean maybe is it a possibility they're
not allowed to enter video into evidence
i mean i don't know i don't know why
they wouldn't but well i mean it's an
article and the article has a video so i
feel like it wouldn't be right
a little further along in the article
i'm going to ask you whether you made
this
this comment
um
if we have a sea of people we will shut
down the streets if we shut down
everything if we flood the capitol
building go inside these are public
buildings we own them we own these
buildings do you understand that we own
the buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings
did you say that in connection with the
fund the wall demonstration in february
of 2019. and because it's about the fun
the wall demonstration i knocked the uh
after she was sworn in and the member of
congress and david
to what she
it i
inclined to breathe what's going on
let's move on
did you say that
i don't recall you're using cnn and
they've chopped up my words so many
times they've lied about me so many
times i mean
just like a video any conspiracy
theories
oh you believe in q a right oh
here we go no i did i did not say i
believe in humanity
this is relevant
let me guess what px84 please as well
okay so under oath she said she doesn't
believe me now the other videos that are
relevant to this she didn't say that
don't say she doesn't believe in them
she said she didn't say that she
is that your
face karen being so smart over here
paying attention to the words
um so this is a video question this is
why women should rule the world by the
way
i object unless he assures us that this
is the complete
clip not
selected that pieces
that is the entire we haven't touched it
your honor okay i'm not saying you
touched it right well this is on
that you're prepared to play this i
think your responsibility and i'm asking
the court to require this or object
is to make sure that this is not taken
out of it is this the video that you
sent me
i think you should be recording yeah so
i think this whole time he was just
setting the quotes up for what she said
absolutely and now it's her to say
the speed with which this proceeding had
to go forward we have been denied the
opportunity to issue subpoenas to get
records to do precisely what mr bob
would like me to do in fact mr bob
objected to all of those things and said
we don't want them to do those things so
the idea now that he is objecting to us
playing a portion of his own client's
words she can defend herself quite ably
she will tell us if it's out of context
or if it's q anon or something else
first of all
what is this again this is a video we
believe of the congresswoman making a
statement
and where did it come from it came from
uh the the cnn article links to it
uh from facebook
so this is but this was pulled off of
what the internet
well it was it was oh jesus christ
what's the internet what's the internet
what the hell is the internet question
1995 today's show explaining what email
is
that's what was there that's what was
there yes okay if you made any
alterations no sir are you aware of any
offense no sir
okay what's this w w dot thing at the
beginning what is that what is that i
think you can now ask the witnesses
about it can we can we play the video
please okay great they can ask him
in washington dc on february 23rd and
protest and march with me at 8 am really
please i'm begging you
if we have
i okay if we have a sea of people if we
shut down the streets if we shut down
everything if we flood the capitol
building flood all the government
buildings go inside these are public
buildings we own them
we own these buildings
do you understand that we own the
buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings you know what
february 23rd may be kind of cold we're
going to go inside we're going to be
warm
and then we're going to demand
that our federal government serve we the
people because we're sick and tired of
their ways
we're sick and tired of the corruption
see here's the issue
here's the issue america they think that
we're stupid and they treat us like
we're stupid and we allow it
we allow it
well no more we're not going to allow it
any more
we want solutions to the problems we
want to take care of america america is
first americans come first with
americans taxpayer dollars
we're done
we're done
and we have a massive list of grievances
okay we have a huge list of grievances
and that's why on february 23rd
in washington dc
at 8 am
we're gonna march in protest and i am
telling you to get your butt there i'm
begging all of you to be there and be
there let's make this huge there's a lot
of really really great people organizing
this
you don't even know
it's green that's you neither does she
she doesn't recall either
in that clip
you were urging people to come to
washington and flood the capitol right
what year was that
you tell me in this green i believe it
was for february 23rd 2019 right
there was no violence that day we
peacefully protested fair enough but my
point is to ask you the question
you were urging people for that
demonstration to flood the peacefully
protest with me and enter the capitol
and and ask our lawmakers to
serve the american people
you guys know she's under oath right now
right
so so now you remember giving that
statement right
now that we've watched the video i
remember that now that your memory has
been jogged a little bit do you remember
talking now my recall sentences have
been heightened being done now that i
saw the thing yeah
that demonstration was peaceful right
and and you remember that you said we
can do it peacefully right of course i
only believe in peaceful demonstrations
i do not support violence
in fact what you said is we can do it
peacefully we can i hope we don't have
to do it the other way i hope not but we
should feel like we will
if we have to
because we are the american people that
was another statement that you made in
the same presentation right that was in
your cnn article and i don't trust cnn
as of course yeah why why
i don't think that that video was that
helpful
i'm not i just don't recall i'm not
recalling saying specifically that
you're saying it doesn't it helps her it
helps you totally and the fact that this
thing about the violence wasn't in there
i'll move on your honor unless he's
using i mean like one is to say like you
know flood the capitals to say like
there's like some
history of that thought in her mind but
then also using as a means of saying
like oh you you said you didn't remember
himself and you kind of denied it and
then we can do cameras outside unless
that sounds a tactic
i'm serious we need to we need to
we need to
get back to task
ms green did you or any member of your
government or campaign staff
communicate
with anthony aguero
about the events of january 6th prior to
january 6th i don't recall
um did you or any member of your
staff either congressional staff or
campaign staff communicate with somebody
named dustin stockton
prior to january 6th i don't think i
know who that is okay
um
how about jennifer lawrence not the
actress
but jennifer lawrence was involved in
conservative politics did you or any
member of your congressional campaign
staff do you never learn
prior to january 6th about the
demonstrations that were planned for
that day i don't recall i don't think i
know who that is
[Music]
we better start playing some actual
videos that show
the actual thing or congressional staff
ms green
uh provide any support
for any demonstrations that occurred on
january 6 2021
i i have no idea i don't think so i
don't know
did you or any member of your staff
provide information advice
funds printed material
the promise of a public statement
to withhold a public statement anything
along those lines
in connection with the demonstrations
that were planned for january sixth i
don't remember i don't think so
and if somebody were to come in here and
say oh yeah she gave us support for our
demonstrations you'd say i don't
remember that
that didn't happen
i
i'm not sure what you're saying i think
you're speculating that's hypothetical
prior to january 6 2021 you heard that
people were planning to enter the
capitol on january 6th
uh and engage in violence right
i don't know i object that i think
that's the fifth time
no chance question
no
never heard that from anybody
no
yeah
and prior to january 6 2021 you were
aware that people were gonna
make noise outside the capitol as a
means to disrupt the proceedings inside
the capitol is that fair no i have no
idea what you're talking about okay
and prior to january 6 2021 had you
heard that people were planning to enter
the capitol building illegally
in order to disrupt the electoral
account process no absolutely not i
don't know anything about that
okay
your honor it's uh i think 12 45 is well
let's talk about that how much longer do
you think it is
you know
probably an hour all right well why
don't we take an i'm going to change
let's take an hour and let's be back
here at
12 45 so that's 145 right
could i respectfully ask for to make it
45 minutes only 40 comments you want to
make it 12 30 i mean 130 i'm sorry i'm
i'm cold challenged one o'clock 1 30 45
minutes with you mr box
in 45 minutes which will be one third
thank you sir
everybody back at 1 30.
okay so it looks like they're gonna take
a lunch here and uh karen i know you
kind of have a heart out here soon um so
as we watch marjory taylor green
leave the courtroom you you said you
thought that the video helped or not
heard her why why do you say that
i mean first of all it was 2019 right it
was
um
not had nothing to do with january 6.
number one number two as she pointed out
there was no violence that day nothing
bad happened
number three she was urging people to
exercise their
first amendment right you know to come
and
tell the politicians what they think i
mean how does that help
you know how does that hurt her in any
way if anything it it supports exactly
what she's saying which is yeah she
calls for peaceful protests and
and guess what happens peaceful protest
so
if if something happened on january 6 i
mean
why where is the evidence of what she
did on january 6. it wasn't in the
opening statement and so far we haven't
seen a single thing other than a cnn
article which she has successfully been
able to say well i don't trust cnn
they're twisting my words so aren't
there videos out there is there not
anything about what she did or said that
they can play about about january 6. i i
i hope they have more i can't believe
they only have an hour i this to me you
have marjorie taylor green under oath
you can ask her every question you want
about january 6 and and what led up to
it i think she should be on the stand
for
a day a full day under cross-examination
which is what this is because she's a
hostile witness so they're able to
cross-examine her typically that would
be
not allowed unless you are an adverse
witness or a hostile witness
um
can you explain the difference between
the two
adverse like what that means
so normally when when you have the
burden and you are calling a witness and
it's your witness you have to ask what's
called uh direct examination questions
and
which means you're not allowed to lead
the witness you're not allowed to ask
leading questions it's you know so what
happened next you know this is is and
then what happened i mean that those are
basically your questions so you know
directing your attention to january 6
you know
were you
there that day yes tell me what happened
you know like what happened next and
what happened next and what happened
next i mean that's what a direct
examination is and then when you're done
putting your evidence on
then you uh the opposing counsel gets to
what's known what's called cross-examine
the witness and those are leading
questions and that's you know isn't it
true that you said
this isn't it true that you did that
isn't it true
you know those are the
isn't it true questions right um
and and that's called cross-examination
and it's and it's very specific you know
on direct you're not allowed to ask
cross-examination type questions and on
you know and on on cross typically you
don't ask direct you know leading i'm
sorry open-ended questions because you
want to control the witness and get your
narrative out you don't want them to you
know say say those things so that's just
sort of sort of um
the rules of evidence in every courtroom
across america you know that's just sort
of what happens but um there's something
called an adverse witness or a hostile
witness and um and and that's what that
that's what she is here meaning she's
not going to even though the plaintiff
has the burden of proof so they need to
call her as a witness she's not a
witness for them right she's she's
um
she's going to say things um that are
adverse to the plaintiff's position so
they ask the judge to designate her an
adverse witness or a hostile witness and
if the judge does that that permits
the person who's calling her in this
case the petitioners to cross-examine
her and that's what this is this that's
why this looks more like a
cross-examination than a direct
examination because that's what it is
um and when you cross-examine someone
like this you know cross-examination
i mean my husband just had a trial where
the main witness was cross-examined by
my husband who's a criminal lawyer for
six days
i mean cross-examination can take you
know it's not something that you do
quickly
especially when you have a witness like
this when you have a witness this
important this big and i i think you um
i think you have her on the stand you
don't want to go too long because then
you sort of annoy the judge and and sort
of fatigue you know the watch the people
who are watching but i think a day a
full day of marjory taylor green would
be appropriate here i would say it's
much more than one more hour and i would
start hitting that hitting her with with
things that help your case i mean i on i
have not seen one thing yet
uh other than the fact that she looks
like she's being evasive and i don't
recall i don't recall i don't recall
um you know other than that i haven't
seen one thing yet that helps the
plaintiff you know nothing they haven't
brought out their strongest evidence if
it exists i mean i assume it exists
right
you guys keep saying there's videos out
there and there's all these things out
there
um i you know i haven't
i i you know i i haven't followed it as
closely as you have frankly um so i just
don't recall you know sound like her
what exactly the evidence is against her
um but whatever it is if it's out there
that he better come back from lunch and
he better hit hard with that and
whatever the the and i would play the
videos because you know those are her
words and she can't say oh it's cnn
taking it out of context twisting my
words i don't know i don't know i don't
know play the videos of her words on
january 6 or on january 5th or on
january 3rd or whenever those those
occurred play those videos play her
words and and show your put your best
foot forward and take take back the
narrative the commissioner has lost the
narrative here so let me let me show you
let me show the video because it was
hard to hear in the in the clip i think
we have the video here i'm going to
reshow it here i i've got to download it
let's it's only like 20 30 seconds let's
let's reshow this one real quick if we
have a sea of people if we shut down the
streets if we shut down everything if we
flood the capitol building flood all the
government buildings go inside these are
public buildings we own them
we own these buildings
do you understand that we own the
buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings
so i think i think um
the video
um in the context that he tried to use
it is irrelevant um i think if he would
have said what was your mindset on
january 6 have you ever had this mindset
before about protest have you ever said
these things before about prior protests
that even if they ended up
peaceful did you have the mindset that
if they weren't peaceful and you would
have to use violence that you may do
that right so if you would i think if he
would have questioned a little better
before cueing up the video um and again
he kept asking the same question but
that part but that thing but that part
that he keeps talking about the if
necessary use violence that wasn't on
the video
he didn't play that
he didn't he didn't play he didn't play
if if necessary he said that was in the
scene that's my point the video who
played did not that that to me is the
only phrase of that whole video matters
that matters
and he didn't play it or i didn't i
missed it and i didn't hear it but he
didn't play that where that i think is
is in the cnn part where she's like well
i don't recall saying that part of it
because it's not on the video and my
words are taken out of context by them
so if that's on video play that part of
the video you're right if necessary use
violence yeah yeah do you have the video
where she is
and it's before january 6 but it's about
uh where she comes outside the white
house that's right that's right that one
can you find that one for me comment the
people in the comments are saying that
was in the video maybe i missed it you
know and if that's the case then yes i
would i would focus on that
right i didn't hear her say that if
that's on that video
you know i i then then i i apologize i i
did miss that part well and and i think
but i think that's relevant though is
what you're saying is that is that your
what what
they're asking the judge to do in the
case of that video is for the judge to
say that she is not allowed to be on a
ballot in this administrative hearing
because she said that one phrase in a
video in 2019 that's not related to
january 6 and i think what you're saying
is that's not enough to get her off the
ballot right now this may damage her
politically i and i believe that this
testimony is very damaging politically
and the reason why is because people are
going to be able to cut clips of this
thing and make her into what just
appears to be an outright liar
um don't forget they have to show that
she was part of an insurrection right
correct and 2019 not an insurrection in
fact she pointed out it wasn't even
violent so i don't understand how that
helps at all
get to january 6 get to the actual
insurance actual insurrection because
that's all that's even if
her mindset was
a thousand times to use violence use
violence abuse violence even if they can
prove that if that wasn't her mindset on
january 6
it doesn't matter and they have to prove
by a very
low burden preponderance of the evidence
that her mindset
and that she did on january 6
basically encourage this insurrection
you know that she participated in this
insurrection in some way and that and
they need to show that and so far what
have they shown that has anything to do
with january 6 and i i i hope the
evidence is there and if it is they got
to start showing it
i'm going to i'm going to play it yeah
so context here is this the video that
we're going to play is actually from
december 2020 so before
she ever took the oath
this is where she was at the white house
already planning january 6th
and and uh um
this is like you said this is before but
this is about specific events of january
6. so this is a video where she is
talking about the events of january 6.
uh make sure yeah i get the volume here
let's go
just finished with our meetings here at
the white house this afternoon we had a
great planning session for january 6
objection we aren't going to let this
election be stolen by joe biden and the
democrats president trump won by a
landslide
call your house reps call your senators
from your states we've got to make sure
they're on board and we already have a
lot of people engaged okay stay tuned
and and like and i know i think i
already know what karen's gonna say here
she's gonna say where does she say well
karen you're gonna say where in the hell
tony does she say in this video that
there's going to be a violent
insurrection just call your senators
right and that's look that that's
that's not that's your absolute
fundamental right that is not being an
insult like again regardless of what her
intention is here of this video because
her intent is not does not play into
what her words actually are right or
does it but where's the evidence where's
the evidence of her right right so this
video isn't evidence yeah yeah so i mean
i look at this and i say well the other
lawyer is saying january 3rd and on is
where things count but here is an
example of where she was already putting
the steps forward to object no but yes
but she said call your senator call your
congressman that's not a violent right
no yeah definition of an insurrection is
the violent overthrow
of
of a government okay and you're
advocating the violent violent it has to
be violent it's not enough to you know
all the people who went to court to say
that um i think the election was stolen
and there was fraud that's not an
insurrection that's actually you're
right you have a right to protest and to
try and and object to um an election
frankly and to call your senators call
your congressman you're allowed to do
that in fact you're encouraged to do
that that's again one of the fundamental
bedrocks of our democracy where is there
was a there there's clearly an
insurrection that day right there was an
attempt of a violent overthrow of of uh
you know just
whether you want to call it overthrowing
the government or stopping the election
or you know the peaceful transfer of
power whatever it was it's clear there
was a violent insurrection that day
you know at the end of the day where is
the evidence that she
encouraged it participated in it was
part of it there has to be that evidence
and if there isn't that evidence this is
game over and so far as i've seen
nothing
so so let me ask you because
you're saying specifically and i want
the audience to be clear on this karen
is saying specifically the game over is
not that there's evidence out there that
uh other than what we see in public on
social media
um in a possible
expulsion of congress in a possible
criminal trial even if that is if that
is the possibility that the doj would
bring a case against her what you're
saying specifically is this evidence
here does not allow this judge in this
moment to make the administrative action
to take her off of the primary ballot um
and and regardless of criminality or
what evidence there is a criminality i
don't know i don't know exactly what the
uh partitioners have access to as far as
you know what they can get you know what
what evidence they can gather up which
if they have something maybe that's the
huge bombshell that we're waiting for
here um but but i think what you're
saying is specifically that
in this moment for this judge to make
this decision to take her off the ballot
for this primary race
so far
kfa has not seen the meat and potatoes
to make sure that she cannot appear on
this ballot and that judge is probably
not going to make that decision um
because like you said he's not going to
be quote unquote wrong uh past an
appellate court right like no judge
wants their decision overturned by an
appellate court and i mean unless
they're just dying to be overturned but
i don't think any judge wants their
rulings to be overturned right they want
to be correct in other words if it does
get appealed they want their decision to
stand that's right especially in a case
this strong i mean
you know this i'm sorry this this hypo
this high profile he's not going to
um yes absolutely the judge is going to
is going to be very conservative in the
sense of not politically conservative
but conservative in his ruling he's not
going to do something
where he could be wrong
um
look i'm not happy
that this is what you know i say these
things and i i worry that people might
think that i'm somehow supporting
marjorie taylor green or you know
i i'm not i don't like that i'm saying
what the things that i'm saying what i'm
saying is play the bad videos right
right or or the bad text messages or
show the phone call the the phone you
know
the the
um the fact that there was there's phone
activity between
her and
and people who you know then came and
did violent you know things on the
capitol like
show you know it's
at the end of the day when you're in a
court of law it's about evidence it's
not about feelings it's not about
political beliefs it's not about um
anything other than evidence and it has
to be uh it has to be
you know that's why that's why they they
make people go under oath because
you know you you can't lie it has to be
admissible it has to be reliable and it
has to be relevant and um
and i just
you know i'm i i feel like i'm i'm being
more of a um
you know just a a
you know an umpire or whatever calling
falls and strikes like
they're you know put your strong put
your evidence out there and they haven't
done that yet and you know if they're if
there are i don't want to put you guys
on the spot
but if you think there are sort of
smoking gun videos or
or evidence out there that is just so
clear
that's been kind of widely
shared on social media or in the news
i mean maybe maybe play it you know
maybe kind of tease it out and call it
out for the people watching it who can
look out for it i mean i unfortunately
i'm gonna have to leave in a little
while and and i can't believe i have to
miss the afternoon but i have an
appointment that i i can't i can't
change um because i i i really want to
see what this evidence turns out to be
but so i haven't seen it and i'll tell
you that i think we're going to stay
with this we're going to go ahead
weather on lunch we're going to do our
quick session of bonehead of the week um
and and so i appreciate you joining us
karen and i want everyone to understand
this is why i like having karen on the
show is because karen is truly
pro-democracy she believes in
institution she believes in the vote she
believes that the people and our
constitution if we use it wisely will
will turn out the best result it's not
perfect democracy is not perfect justice
is not perfect we all know that
from the the just the piles and piles of
cases that we've seen
um you know in in court that sometimes
certain uh folks in our population
people of color mainly and and poor folk
as well do not receive the the justice
that maybe rich folks and white folks
receive in this country but but but we
can't abandon
pro-democracy values
in in making sure that we get the
authoritarian decision that we want
because as much as you may hate marjorie
taylor green as much as you may
vehemently disagree with her as much as
you think she's vile and she's an
insurrectionist and she caused the
violent insurrection and she was part of
it
she is afforded the same rights as
everyone else and that you would want to
be afforded and let's face it if we
afford her if we the people afford her
those rights then hopefully our rights
will be guaranteed as well so i want
everyone to understand that that is that
is the position that karen has taken
here and i think if there is any
criminal evidence that the doj has that
doesn't mean that these uh
these petitioners would have that
evidence that's not that's not exactly
it so if there is evidence out there
that exists in the world that we do not
have that the petitioners do not have
that gabe cannot uh search here while
he's really trying to find it here no
i'm just kidding um
then we it if it exists and the
department of justice gets their hands
on it and there is criminal activity
then uh hopefully
we do not demand authoritarianism we
demand justice and we demand to be a
pro-democracy and have those
institutions bring marjory taylor green
and anyone else to justice for the
violent insurrection on january 6. now
if you want more
balls and strikes as karen says
please go follow
and subscribe to midas touch legal af
podcast because karen is the co co-host
with michael popock on wednesday's
edition of legal af
and
our one of our favorite legal show here
but this is why i like to have karen on
is because she does care about those
institutions she does care about
democracy and and that is most important
to me um when we are trying to get our
message out there is that we're
pro-democracy we are not for merrick
garland being a bill barr that's not
what i want i want merrick garland to be
the attorney general of the united
states and i want him to direct his
united states attorneys to bring anyone
to justice whether it be january 6 or
any other thing
in a way that does not violate someone's
constitutional rights and does it
correctly as best as they possibly can
and that our democracy can deliver
justice i that's what i want from
merrick garland um and i hope that's
what we see i think that's what we're
going to see i think karen will agree
with you but karen before we leave tell
us where we can find legal af tell us
where we can find karen on all the
tweety tweets and trendy trends because
i know everyone wants to meet
um so
legal af you can get it pretty much
wherever you get your podcast but
youtube is a pretty easy place to to get
it you just put in legal af and you'll
you'll get that or you can go to the
midas touch
uh subscribe to their channel and it's
on there um also i'm i have a twitter
account i think i'm i think it's at kfa
legal yeah we got it right there on the
screen right there on the screen there
you go yeah okay
so go over and follow follow care and
you've got a you've got a mug i think
that has your logo on it right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i already put that in the dishwasher
okay oh okay well well go go check out
the legal af mugs um and and help karen
out let's get her twitter account up
let's get her some twitter followers
over there um she she's been trying to
get more on twitter i think i think
you're doing a great job trying to uh
come come to the tweety tweets and the
trinity you know i was a i was a
prosecutor for almost 30 years and
because of that i really did not have a
social media presence because we just
couldn't you know we really couldn't be
on social media so i had a you know like
a little personal facebook kind of
account that you know you just you watch
your your cousins and nieces and nephews
sort of you know that that kind of
account but it's only until i left a
year ago where now i can sort of get on
social media so i'm i'm starting to get
my sea legs and you know
they're i'm starting to learn kind of
how to do it and i'm i'm really enjoying
it but that's why my social media is a
little bit you know delayed it was
because i just couldn't do it for many
many years but i'm i'm getting into it
now so well everyone go ahead i was
gonna say i'm you know tony and i both
appreciate it and i'm sure everyone
who's watching especially today but
other times if they come into the
podcast for your show
uh or when you pop into our show um
really appreciate the legal perspective
and that you know you said 30 years as
prosecutors so it's you know gonna it's
not going to trump any armchair lawyer
that uh decided to become a legal expert
over cobits hey easy on pop easy
crying out loud easy on
guarantee no i'm i'm kidding i'm kidding
we've had po poc on and and pop those
poppins but we we enjoy carrying for
karen's much prettier than pop let's
face it though
well hey i think and i've said this
before i think women should rule the
world i think men have done a horrible
job at it uh maybe that's the situation
that we're in today and why we're here
um with with some of the things that
we've done um and specifically men like
trump um so i i think i think if we can
get ourselves in a position where uh
people who are level-headed who have a a
better opportunity to actually govern
and do policy
um i think i think we'll have more
outcomes of justice so karen thank you
thank you for joining us thank you for
having me
yes it was fantastic i know i know i
messaged you late at night last night
when we found out this marjorie taylor
green thing i was super excited if you
said yes so thank you very much for
coming and yeah i appreciate you having
me i was i really uh it gave me an
excuse to get to watch this so okay
great great great great well you you
have a good appointment and and that
maybe we'll have you down next week when
we find out more about what happens yeah
i have a feeling i'm going to miss the
the good stuff so
well you know it's recorded it's
recorded so you'll be able to hear it
thank you karen very much you have a
good afternoon uh we're going to get to
bonehead of the week here thank you
karen bye-bye bye-bye
okay everybody um
well there we go that was you i didn't
yeah i i i take this as an opportunity
you can if you can uh
hold down the fort for like three
minutes oh do you gotta take a piss you
gotta know
oh
you got some things you gotta i gotta i
have a i know i don't know absolutely
absolutely absolutely i just need to
switch from this room to the other room
oh okay great great great yeah let me
let me give some commentary we'll get to
bonehead of the week um and and we'll
come back with bonehead with gabe here
in a second let's do this let's take a
quick break don't go anywhere i promise
we're gonna bone in the week and then
after bone at a week we are going to
stay live we're going to stay live here
um as soon as they come back in the
hearing room it looks like they're going
to come back at 1 30
um which we may or may not be able to
get through bonehead here we may have to
do bonehead as a separate as a uh as a
separate thing i'm i'm not sure we'll
just have to uh figure out time
uh as far as it goes here's what we
normally do for all you new listeners
out there we do two hours every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central on youtube twitter
and twitch so make sure you follow and
subscribe to our youtube channel
uh that's very important that you follow
our our youtube channel that way you
don't miss a single episode because
we're not just on youtube twitter and
twitch we're also on the minus touch
facebook page for all of you out there
who follow my touch on the facebook page
you probably noticed that our podcast is
showing up right there on the books of
face
so like and subscribe or like and and
you can go follow me on facebook if you
want i'm on the books of face i've got
an account over there you just type in
the tony michaels you'll find it but you
can go to thetonymichaels.com you can
find all the places
to follow
our podcast the tony michaels podcast
whether it be youtube twitch twitter or
mind facebook page but make sure you go
over to twitter and follow at tony
michael's pod because that's where the
bonehead of the week pole lives uh bone
of the week is a poll we do we put we
put some contestants up every single
week you
you
the viewer get to vote on who is the
bonehead of the week
and then on fridays normally when we
don't have uh marjorie taylor green
perjuring herself on the stand
live we normally go through bone end of
the week and we do a breakdown and
that's what we're gonna do today
now rather we do it
um here before we get uh restarted here
or we do it uh after we have this um we
will have to make that decision on the
fly here so we will we will try to make
those decisions for you and get you get
you bonehead of the week breakdown but
you can go vote for end of the week and
then we'll break it down every week and
and again if you don't if you want to
watch the show you can watch on youtube
but if you want to listen to the show
you can go to apple google spotify you
can download every single episode this
is a special edition episode we're
working on four hours right now on this
episode now this special edition episode
with marjorie taylor green appearing to
perjure herself on the stand that's what
appears to me it seems like there's
several lies that she's already told
under oath and that are easily prove
easily proven uh false now like karen
said she's trying to do the whole
oh i don't recall i don't remember
you know kind of thing uh you know i
understand that that's that's a thing
that you know she's trying to do not to
perjure herself uh mj here uh says in
super chat kfa legal
is awesome thank you yes we really thank
karen for coming on the show and giving
us her legal analysis um when i found
out last night that there was going to
be a hearing on marjory taylor green
appearing on the ballot and that the
cameras are going to be allowed in the
room like oh we're going to stream that
there's no way we're not going to stream
that um and for our audience i i think
it's a huge a huge thing to see inside
of this hearing uh i think originally
there wasn't gonna be cameras but
marjorie taylor green wanted cameras
there because they wanted to say that
people were gonna spin this into lies
well when you get on the stand in what
appears to be perjuring yourself where
you just lie lie lie lie lie of stuff
that's pretty much provable
um that's where the lies come from
marjorie taylor green hooffoot merge
it really is ridiculous but
this is what we're here to do
um that's what we're here to do is to
show you the truth do not look away
because our democracy is important
and marjorie taylor green
as much as everyone wants her to be
taken off the ballot
in georgia now rather it's the
the ballot that they're working with
today which is the primary ballot
because that's super important uh minus
ken says uh uh marjorie taylor green has
a monopoly on bone end of the week she
actually appears on our bone end of the
week but ken you might be disappointed
but stick around you'll find out who
wins the bone end of the week now but
thank you ken for the super chat
um but our democracy is important and
the ballot that they want to take her
off of is the primary ballot right
it is the primary ballot not not the
ballot
that is
let's see are we coming back here no
this is uh earlier okay
uh it is not the ballot
that would be the general election now
uh you know i think i think a good way
to take marjorie taylor green off the
ballot is to go vote for her opponent
right like
in this primary race specifically um to
go vote for her opponent that way
there's a different republican on the
general election ballot that would be a
good way to take marjorie taylor green
off the ballot uh it really would
whereas right now we're trying to rely
on a judge to make a decision that i i'm
actually in agreeance with uh
karen kfa i think that it's possible
that this judge is gonna take the path
of least resistance and he's gonna kick
this can down the road and he's gonna
say let the people decide right just
kind of what i'm saying
and really honestly i don't know that
that's the wrong decision i don't know
if it's the right decision it depends on
what evidence that the the uh
petitioners here bring up in this second
line of questioning after lunch but um
if gabe is ready we'll go ahead and go
because you're you are you're not no i
am yeah okay well
the only one the only one that remains
is who are the
dishonorable mentions gonna be
oh well you know let's let's go to bone
end of the week because um
lookie there oh
oh the the real bonehead of the week um
here's our here's our contestants this
week marjorie taylor green obviously for
today's ron desantis and greg abbott but
let's let's start the um let's do the
the whole thing where we where we do the
music and then we'll do bone end of the
week and when when the hearing starts
we'll end bonehead of the week and we'll
go back
all right let's start let's start the
music
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we're going to go back to
the hearing here because we've been
streaming for six long hours today
thanks for joining us here at the tony
michaels podcast we do appreciate you uh
staying with us today uh if you're just
joining us or if you've been joining us
all day uh welcome to the tony michaels
podcast where we broadcast every single
weekday monday through friday
every single one of them
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch here's the thing normally we're
only on for two hours today has been a
special event because uh we really
wanted to stream this marjory taylor
green uh testimony we think it's very
important um amanda says need a bathroom
break tony um no i i um i've been taking
secret breaks i have a body double that
sits here
um he sits off and off frame and he has
a voice like no i'm just kidding um
there was a few times where we had some
breaks i was able to um
use the restroom so thank you amanda for
thinking of me but here's the thing we
don't normally we don't normally stream
for six hours
not a normal thing we normally do it two
hours every single weekday noon eastern
11 central on youtube twitter twitch and
now we broadcast from the midas touch
facebook page so if you guys are out
there and you've been listening today
you really you really should go
subscribe to the youtube channel
just go to youtube type in the tony
michaels podcast hit subscribe
that way you don't miss a thing because
here's what i think i'm going to do
because we were really trying to figure
out how this was going to work we had no
idea i didn't know how long this thing
was going to last i i didn't know what
was going to happen in this thing
but we had karen agnipolo kfa from legal
af the podcast that minus touch produces
legal af
on earlier giving live legal commentary
uh during during the hearing
so what i think i'm gonna do for the
podcast directories is i'm gonna take
this episode this this gazillion hours
that we have and we're gonna cut out
some of the parts where kfa is talking
about her legal analysis um we will cut
out bonehead of the week so you guys
make sure you get bonehead of the week
on the directories and then maybe we'll
cut out like some other commentary that
we've done and maybe some significant
parts of the marjorie taylor green
that's some of her testimony i expected
to be honest with you i expected the
marjorie taylor's greens lawyer to spend
a lot more time
on her testimony but it doesn't seem
like they thought they needed much time
to prove it and i think karen agnipolo
kfa from legal af
is correct on this i think the feeling
is
is that this judge is not going to make
a constitutional decision
or what he views as a constitutional
decision
um for
the when when
when we're in an administrative type
hearing right like this isn't this isn't
a civil courtroom
this is not a
this is not a uh criminal courtroom
uh thank you mj and ken for the super
chats there now they're both thanking us
for our service today i guess you're
welcome you're welcome now we were going
to be sitting here anyways we're just
streaming longer now i was going to
watch this thing regardless so i might
as well watch it with you i guess
but i believe that this judge
is going to do what uh karen mcnippolo
kfa from legal af says
is that he's going to kick this can down
the road he's going to make it really
easy on himself right so what he's going
to do is he's going to say well this is
a constitutional question this needs to
be
had in a federal court or this needs to
be worked out with congress right
that's what i believe he's gonna say and
he's gonna kick this can they made it
really easy because there's been no real
definitive proof um that the that the
petitioners have provided that would say
that yes undeniably in this courtroom
during this hearing during your
testimony she is an insurrectionist she
called for violence like there's no
you order the co-red you order the
co-red you goddamn right i did you know
there's not that moment right
there's not that moment there hasn't
been a piece of evidence that really
spells out for this judge i believe who
is probably
leaning towards
uh
probably leaning toward marjorie
favoring in marjorie taylor's green's
favor anyways
i don't think there's anything that's
shown that would justify him to not kick
this can down the road and what i mean
by that it's not that i want him to i
just i that's what this [ __ ]
knucklehead's gonna do
right that's what he's gonna do here uh
ty rots thank you for the super sticker
thank you ty
ty's one of our favorite over on um
twitter you guys should go follow ty she
writes for occupy democrats by the way
so go check out her articles at occupy
denver we've actually featured a couple
of her articles here
on the tony michaels podcast because i
think she's rude about those oath
keepers that i keep talking about i keep
talking about the oath keepers they keep
talking about the proud boys they keep
talking about roger stone and i keep
talking about that god damn decision
made out in california by car judge
carter
about john eastman's emails and how they
were not protected by attorney-client
privilege because john eastman and
donald trump committed a
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding
that is why judge carter decided that
those are criminal and that is why
they're not protected
by attorney-client privilege a federal
judge has ruled
that donald trump and john eastman
committed crimes
conspiracy to obstruct congress official
proceeding is the actual charge or the
actual crime that he accuses them of in
his in his judgment
on
the fact that these emails that they
were they were planning the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup are not protected by
attorney client privilege
but that is significant and the reason
why that's significant is again and and
when questioning
marjorie taylor green the petitioner's
lawyer even brought up martial law which
i thought oh man maybe he's gonna come
in
here with some real evidence
some real evidence
because there is actual evidence out in
the open in the public that we have
that shows that the oath keepers were
waiting
they were waiting
on an order from someone
to order the qrf which is the stockpile
weapons across the potomac in virginia
to bring them across the river
so that way they were armed
that way they could commit or commit a
coup
by donald trump declaring martial law
and deputizing the oath keepers
stewart rhodes was in charge of that qrf
or that stockpile weapons he was waiting
for the order
and it just so happens that one of his
lieutenants who has pled guilty to
conspiracy of sedition
which is important when you talk about
the qrf and the stash of weapons
he was protecting roger stone he was
standing right next to roger stone the
entire
the entire time the insurrection was
happening on january 6.
now it's known that roger stone has a
personal connection with the president
and probably has a personal line
with the president where he could
either call or text him i don't know i
would imagine that roger stone maybe
even had burners on him that day who
knows i guess maybe we'll find out in a
court of law one of these days
but also that is what is significant
is that
stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers
who whose lieutenant was protecting
standing next to roger stone the entire
time the insurrection was happening
met with enrique tario
the day before
and the context there is that they met
in a parking garage in washington dc
where enrique tario was ordered not to
be it was unlawful for him to be in the
city of washington dc at that moment
and there was a
protest where he had burned a sign off
of a church they tore a sign down off a
church and they'd ordered him out of the
city but he came in anyways to meet with
stewart rhodes
the founder of the oak keepers where his
lieutenant
would be standing next to roger stone
waiting for orders apparently
from someone
to give to stewart rhodes that martial
law had been that had been declared
and that the stack stockpile weapons
could be brought across the potomac
to stop those antifa and black lives
matter and even marjorie taylor
in her testimony here in open court
brings up antifa and black lives matter
that racist [ __ ]
of course they could they they do this
[ __ ] where they conflate these two
issues
and the reason why is because they
wanted black lives matter and antifa
there that day but they weren't but they
wanted them there they wanted so bad for
antiva and black lives matter to commit
violence
so that way it was very easy for the
president united states at the time the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself donald trump
to declare martial law and to deputize
the oath keepers so they could arrest
members of congress
and it is very important to know
that stuart road and stuart rhodes and
enrique tario met the night before
and the reason why it's super super
super duper
significant is because the proud boys
were supposed to be
the security force that was going to be
next to roger stone that day
but they switched it for some reason for
some reason the proud boys decided they
wouldn't protect roger stone that the
oath keepers were i wonder if it's
because the proud boys didn't have the
stockpile weapons it was the oath
keepers who had the possibility of
bringing the qrf across the potomac
but the reason why also that the proud
boys are significant in that they
were in cahoots with roger stone is one
of the people that have charged an
indictment with enrique tario
is another lieutenant but of the proud
boys and he has pled guilty
to the conspiracy listen to this
the conspiracy
to an obstruct
an official
proceeding
that is very
very very important
very important in this case when we
watch
that that a judge a federal judge in
california judge carter
says that john eastman
and donald trump were committing a crime
that's why they're not protected
by attorney-client privilege and the
crime that he thinks they've committed
that would not protect their
attorney-client privilege is the
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding
and we have the proud boys
pleading guilty to that exact charge
this is not this is not
this is not
um
hard to understand
it's not hard to follow the bouncing
ball here we know this out in public now
and marjorie taylor green has done
nothing more today
than to maybe maybe keep herself on the
ballot but only to reveal to us
the real plans
of january 6th she lays it out when
she's asked about martial law
and of course they tried to cover their
tracks of course they did of course she
made videos the president united states
made a video
in the rose garden trying to cover his
tracks when they knew it wasn't gonna
work and when they knew it wasn't gonna
work is when mike pence
did refuse to leave the capitol
when he refused to leave and he refused
to go along with the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup and his
his role in it
mike pence refused
to not do the thing that he was that he
was constitutional constitutionally set
out to do
was his duty
was to preside over the proceeding
where the states would certify the vote
that they had already certified
folks
all's mike pence was doing was opening
up the oscar envelope and reading the
results
this objection [ __ ] that she's talking
about oh democrats have objected before
it is the right of a member of congress
to vote to object to a certification she
is correct
that is your right you do have that
right as a congressperson
but that doesn't mean that it's going to
happen
and just because you have the right
doesn't mean you have an alternative
which is what she was talking about in
one of those videos that was shown when
she didn't recall i don't recall if
that's me i don't know i [ __ ]
my memory just went blank
now the question is to me
is
when will we see
results from the department of justice i
think that's the real question after
today the question after today isn't
rather marjorie taylor green's gonna be
on the ballot or not because honestly if
the constituents inside her district
don't want her on the ballot they can go
vote for her primary challenger a
primary challenger
they will be able to anyways these
ballots are already printed they said
that at the beginning of the hearing
it's not like they're actually trying to
take her off the ballot in the general
election because she's not even on that
ballot yet
she has to win the primary she has
challengers she's likely to win
that's why they're protesting
um her being on the ballot in the first
place the why they uh petitioned to take
her off when using this
this
insurrection law
to take her off the ballot i think it's
very significant though that she is laid
forth in her testimony
uh more lies more perjury it seems
and
the other the other thing that i think
is probably discounted is how much this
politically
not only damages her but it damages the
republican party i'm sure the republican
party is not [ __ ] excited that
marjorie taylor greene is sitting for a
couple hours testifying about how no no
i'm not an insurrectionist don't look
over here
don't believe your lying eyes don't
believe your lying eyes then i'm an
insurrectionist all the while matt gatz
the the accused child sex trafficker
sits in the front
giving links to my i mean i'm assuming
there i'm making assumptions there that
he's winking at her
he might be taking notes someone uh said
while ago taking notes on how not to
answer questions during testimony
but i don't think this is good for the
republican party this is not good for
their politics for her to be sitting
here
folks we now have hours and hours and
hours
of marjorie taylor greene
being the leader of their party
uh looks like the proscenis are going to
come back let's see if we can listen in
the matter is there before we close is
there anything else
no other than your honor you've really
done a fine job in a very extraordinary
way thank you thank you flattery
i'll come i'll come in after hours if
you need me to appreciate everybody
who's scrambling to be here so with that
i think that concludes the hearing
everybody
does this
obviously we're not going to zoom in the
back of our head right there
not here right
there's there's the culprit there's the
slide
so so um i didn't expect it to end quite
quite like that i didn't know if the
judge
was going to make a decision it didn't
seem like it when they started the
closing arguments because he said you
know the briefing and then the right
it's uh due by next thursday so yeah the
next six days right they'll they'll get
the they'll get the brief and and um the
just i so so we're gonna make news on
this again this is how this always
happens
um it always comes back around i'm sure
i'm almost positive almost positive
that uh marjorie taylor green this isn't
the last time she ends up on the
bonehead of the week paul oh for sure um
just for this particular instance this
particular thing i mean there's there'll
be plenty other things that you'll show
up like i look at the situation and i
say yeah okay
we were you know we were obviously
hoping for something to come out that
was definitely revealing
um
that that would have been like hey
there's a smoke gun obviously there is
evidence or there are there are moments
right that reveal intent you know uh
whether or not explicitly saying go you
know violence she definitely has a
well i don't know why
political ads uh or you see your
facebook posts or whatever there is
actual violence being promoted right
right i mean yeah i think the
the most significant evidence
of marjorie taylor's words
and her argument against those words was
was probably the best case to be made in
this hearing
with the public information right
which the where she says we cannot allow
a peaceful transfer of power when she
says those words we cannot allow a
peaceful the only the only right the
only and she actually did it in quotes
the only other alternative to a peaceful
transfer of power quote unquote is a
violent
transfer of power which would be
a an insurrection violence and she says
i don't promote violence i don't promote
violence well
promoting that you can't have
a peaceful transfer of power right is
there if you can't yeah if it can't be
this right look you got to look at it
like binary right if it's not a one it's
a zero and there's nothing in between so
if it's not peaceful
then it's the opposite of peaceful which
would be
right
violent right or or some something that
is uh
you know definitely more intense than
peaceful and i think that's the most
significant piece of evidence that was
shown here today and if the judge if the
judge does surprise me
uh and and say marjorie taylor green is
not allowed to be on the ballot which i
will be very surprised if he makes that
decision right i will be very surprised
i did not sit here for almost eight
hours listen to all this and not come to
the conclusion uh lightly that i
actually think this judge is going to
make the decision he's going to kick it
and he's going to blame it on the
constitution and he doesn't get to make
constitutional decisions is the thing
that he's going to say he's going to
blame it on congress and that a federal
judge should make this decision and
really honestly he's going to say the
people should make this decision in an
election he's gonna say there's always
an opportunity if the if the evidence
arises that she is an insurrectionist to
remove her
from the ballot uh before the general i
mean there's so many different things he
could say there's so many different uh
scapegoats that he could use right to
not take i mean i i didn't i i didn't
sit here with you and and all of the
like our viewers which by the way thank
you yes for those who stuck with us and
chatted with us and had your own little
side conversations uh we always enjoy it
so please every day we have every
weekday we have a show right every
monday through friday and i do want to
point out because chris and give smiles
here kristin is a is a local hate
watcher and we love we love having
kristin and i think we gathered up a few
new hate watchers today yeah so everyone
let's tell them every single week day
you can come hate watch monday friday
right two hours every single day on
youtube twitter twitch don't forget to
go the minus touch facebook page and
promote over their trolls get in the
algorithm there and really help there so
if you got like four devices in russia
and you're watching on all four that
would be get them up different yeah yeah
you're great yeah right make sure that i
will say like i didn't know
i i i'm on the west coast i was up at 6
30 i woke up at 6 20 a.m
for a 6 30 a.m a k 9 30 a.m east coast
time
i've
i've been i have not
taken a break outside of like going to
walk my dogs or something but i've been
pretty much been i've been talking to
you or talking to you and karen or just
watching and listening
and um i will say if anything
uh
this does obviously she's under oath
right she was under oath she said things
she um
she said uh things that can be used now
um as precedent for what you know it to
purge herself in in a later suit or or
what have you but also keep in mind this
is the first
sitting
uh member of congress
senate you know just politician
that has had to testify under oath
to
uh to to discuss january 6 and their
role in january 6 right and that's what
this really boils down to it's like what
did they do around january 6 that would
either make her
uh ineligible for for the ballot and
like we said you know it probably won't
happen they'll probably kick it down the
can because obviously this is like
someone else's decision to be made right
but um
what is said here is on the record under
oath will be used if need be for
further cases
um or follow-up
um
and
i think i think you make a good point i
think you make a good point because like
i said anything she said here under oath
um is it can and will be used against
her in a criminal court because i think
that's the significance here that a lot
of people might miss in this decision if
they're disappointed which i think
you're gonna be if you're hoping she'll
be removed from the ballot is that this
is not a criminal court that's not what
this is so the bar
the bar to remove her from the ballot in
this instance is a hell of a lot lower
than even convicting her in a criminal
court it's like a criminal case they're
gonna have to have even way more
evidence right than what they would even
collected uh today and presented to the
judge and again we appreciate all you
guys uh sticking with us here's what
we're gonna do
tomorrow i'm going to edit um this down
to put on the audio
directories so
normally what we do is after the show is
done we post our audio version on all
the directories spotify google
you can go download
all the podcasts over there and get
caught up if you're not
but we're going to edit this down for
the audio version
um to about a couple hours probably like
we normally do we'll put a lot of the
kfa back and forth we had we'll put this
in the end we'll put bonehead of the
week in there but we're also going to
cut out bone of the week and post it on
youtube like we normally do so you guys
can find that because it will be
difficult to find it in this eight hours
of video so we'll do that for you as
well um
make sure to subscribe to the youtube
channel and so you don't miss any other
episodes rather you're rather you're
hate watching or you're love watching
right because we love having you here
and we're glad that you guys stuck
around all day we really wanted to air
this we thought it was significant i had
no idea it would go eight hours but it
did and we stuck with it all day because
you guys stuck with us so we really
appreciate that make sure
make sure you go to our podcast page um
on twitter as well at toni michael's pod
follow us there you'll get the bow net
of the week poll every single week
today was friday and it was a little
unconventional because of this marjorie
taylor green hearing right but we did do
bone end of the week as we promised in
the technical second hour of the podcast
it did happen
so we try promises made promises kept we
it was very very short yes but
it's only because we had a very short
recessed image right right i think we
had about the we had about 20 minutes to
do the weekend which normally we do it
we it usually ends up being about 40
minutes right yeah it's usually about 40
45 minutes we actually actually give
you know in in-depth or
well we want to do a little surfing we
didn't do a lot of surfing today
and it's been pretty much locked in on
that right and at the end of the podcast
you know we always say surf's up
[ __ ] but we almost can't say
surf's up today
what i want to say is
go take a [ __ ] nap like like uh get
some rest this was uh this was brutal
today in some parts uh with deputy dog
as uh marjorie taylor green's attorney
was super boring he couldn't lean into
the mic he couldn't figure out how to
zoom he didn't know technology
they made really stupid arguments what
do they think the arguments that need to
be pulled from this and people need to
go check out is the argument that he
tried to make when he tried to um make
it seem as if the kkk
didn't incite an insurrection they were
they were just um and he tried to try to
make it like compare what marjorie
taylor
green has done with the kkk it was kind
of gross i mean not kind of it is
[ __ ] gross yeah but that's what he
did in a in a court
in atlanta georgia of all places uh this
this attorney for margie taylor green
made that comparison uh from marja
taylor greene to the kkk uh and it's um
not surprising really i i think that's
par for the course but i i do want to
thank everybody again for saying and
gabe
man gabe was on almost all day long
mm-hmm i'm sure
i'm sure that there's someone there's a
a nap in my face oh yeah yeah because
gabe was up early because gabe yeah i
woke up i woke up fed the dogs sat down
in the other because i usually do it in
this room but i had to do in the other
room uh that early in the morning
and
uh yeah did you even get the stream soda
today at all
you know what i did get some sodas
during your break yeah you know again if
sodastream wants to oh yeah and
advertising on the show
please i'm not saying we're not going to
but
this guy yes i did i did get some i had
some earlier i drank it you know oh okay
so you still have the soda see i just i
just drink like water the water right
well i mean it's the same thing i just
put co2 in it you know it's fancy water
yeah fancy yeah
you and your fancy water well uh some
significant things that happened today i
thought the the most boneheaded moment
of almost all of it
on on the petitioner's side uh not mar
there's a lot of boneheaded moments on
marjorie taylor greenside but the
petitioner side is when they played the
clip of independence day i was like oh
my god are we really going to do this
where he's going to play the clip just
so to prove that she knows that those
words
are from independence day and then he
tried to do it again in the closing
remarks and it wasn't i don't know why
he thought that was going to be
effective yeah
if it was
if there was any video that could have
been shown it would have been if like oh
there was ted cruz and there was right i
don't know who else said i would if
let's say hypothetically it was like
cruz and gosar and brooks and holly
right to show that there was a
consistent message in order it was like
hey look we need to do this but i 100
agree like i looked at him like uh it's
getting a little conspiracy like
connecting the like you got red dots or
like lines and dots around here to be
like well it's a quote from a movie
which is actually quote kind of a quote
from a poem which is actually quote from
here like you're trying to make this
connection and i look at and i say
it was a bit of a stretch i get what he
was trying to do but at the same time
it's like it makes it feel like you're
grasping at straws right right and it
didn't really help the argument no it
did well it didn't help any argument
really other than she didn't know what
movie it was or she pretended like she
didn't know what movie it was from right
it was really [ __ ] stupid um i i
think i think um
if they lost the judge like in arguments
that might have been a point where they
actually lost him because they were like
really you're going to play a [ __ ]
clip from a movie because she used one
quote um not that that quote is
insignificant in what she was trying to
say but i don't think playing the clip
or proving that she's watched that movie
before it had anymore
quoting you know right right right i
mean i think i think the language around
the 1776 was a little flimsy from the
petitioner's side but that was a
stronger argument than the stupid
[ __ ] movie quote
yeah i mean you know again again it it
definitely
goes again or goes to the like if you're
going to really go
hammer down the the the code the code
language the code words whatever to show
there was intent or you know malicious
intent um to incite
then
i think there needs to be more examples
especially again from other people from
the party who were you know speaking at
the rally or who are pushing that
narrative or messaging and uh we're
actually the ones who are like
proponents or right right
well i mean in that and that is goes to
the actual case the heart of it and i
think that's the decision that this
judge has to make
was she was she planning and inciting an
insurrection or was she advocating for
the first amendment right right like
what and and for her vote um to to
object what what was her intent and that
is where it's at was she an advocate or
was she an insurrectionist that's kind
of the decision and really the judge
doesn't have to make that decision he
can say i'm going to let someone else
make that decision exactly yeah which i
think is it's a big it's a big thing and
um
is like you know
what at what point are you protected or
not protected under the first amendment
right like the example that karen
discussed with us that we've heard
before is you go into a crowded theater
and you yell fire and if somebody dies
or you know some accident happens you're
not protected by the first amendment you
know in that type of scenario and so you
look at this and say
right because you're inciting something
you're not advocating like you're not an
advocate for the advocate for the safety
of the of the theater you're actually
inciting um something at the theater uh
i actually you posted let's before we go
i want to play
um that video real quick that they
played in open court um and i think you
reposted it here let me um
let me share this screen here because i
think it's significant and and the
reason why is it's because
it actually says the thing
that um
you posted margery taylor green the
quote is um you can't allow
to just transfer power peacefully like
joe biden wants and allow him to become
our president and i think because the
alternative is to violently
not let joe biden become president but
here is that video one more time for the
audience
and this is an important time in our
history
we can't allow this just to just to be
gone you know just to let it go you
can't allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there the mainstream
media for four years talked about
russian collusion conspiracy theories
and lies and demanded investigations
non-stop
into russian collusion
non-stop but yet they refused okay i
just want to let everyone know i didn't
cut that video and then that's that's
her taking the video as well and that's
her on the video yeah as much as she
doesn't recall [ __ ]
this is her now what she said you know
there is truth behind what she said
there is there was voter fraud now it
you know unfortunately for the
republicans that voter fraud was within
their own party right four people from
the villages in florida alone we had the
one guy uh
and both who two of them uh last week
were actually actually pled guilty and
they were received white guy sentences
exactly there's the one trumper who
killed his wife and you know
voted for her on the ballot yeah voted
for him her her mother and his mother
right yeah yeah there's you know so when
when the party looks and say and looks
out and and proclaims voter fraud
it's a little bit of projection because
all the cases that we've actually seen
from voter fraud is within the
republican party and those people who
voted for trump or killed people to vote
for trump um which is insane to think
about right well i mean it is it is they
are trumpers so right right and and it's
like oh you've got uh the aeg of texas
who's like hey
um if anyone can prove that there was
voter fraud meanwhile people like okay
yeah cool there found one here found in
here where's my bounty where's my reward
that you promised
um
but yeah if you look at that you're like
oh where's the actual voter fraud
happening it's within the republican
party so yeah it is projection it is the
party the the same party who says
protect the kids we got to keep them
safe are the same people in those uh
republican seats who are the ones uh
getting caught
right right like actual actually sex
trafficking or child pornography or
child molestation like there's all these
cases that have come up recently and
continue to come up well i mean i mean
think about it just in tennessee we see
where they're trying to pass a bill
where they can make it legal for to
marry children and we have two tennessee
reps one who's been convicted and one
who married a child bride i mean this
this is not this is not a situation
where um
this projection that that marjorie
taylor green then republicans have been
doing since 2016
under the tutelage of the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy's pants donald
trump himself because that's where they
learned this projection it allowed
people to use racism it allowed them to
use hatred and it allowed them to to use
this projection that we're talking about
as a political weapon when before
it wasn't as effective because people
would catch on to your hypocrisy and
they would catch on to your projection
quickly they just completely ignore it
because they don't need to take sides
right like they can donald trump can
hate the coveted vaccine and love it all
at the same time right he can he can
love both of them he can be a sexual
assaulter where he grabs [ __ ] and he
loves women and respects women he's the
most respected women and he can he can
not like black people in white
neighborhoods in suburbia but he can be
the least first racist person in the
room all at the same time i mean this is
this is the thing that they do best and
they're going to continue to do it under
trumpism and the only way to stop them
is not to rely on a judge in georgia to
take them off ballots it's not folks
that is the lesson we need to learn
today is this hearing we we are not
going to stop these fascists from
creating a fascist state like ron
desantis is trying to do in florida
by taking them off ballots the way we
take them off ballots is to [ __ ]
engage and engage in our democracy and
be pro-democracy and go [ __ ] vote and
i don't just mean marking a ballot i
mean getting involved doing what you can
do inside your democracy even talking to
people
i've been saying this for the last week
since ron desantis wanted to ban math in
in florida just ask people around you
who you know
say ask them the question did you hear
that republicans in florida are trying
to ban math that is the question you ask
they're going to say
what what are you talking about because
they have not heard that story right
they will not hear that story yeah they
won't they'll hear daryl hill woke
disney's bad disney's bad disney's bad
but they will not hear the story that
ron desantis is trying to actively
remove
54 uh math books from curriculum in
florida they will not hear that because
they're trying to destroy public
education they're trying to destroy our
democracy little by little uh inch by
inch with inside and that is the whole
point of today and that's why i wanted
to make sure that we aired this it is so
significant is because marjorie taylor
green ultimately she was she wasn't just
an insurrectionist on january 6th she is
still an insurrection she still wants to
tear down our democracy she does not
want our democracy to live she does not
want she does not want equality she does
not want equity for all she definitely
for a hundred percent does not want
liberty for all she does not believe in
that she does not want that she has
projected that into the universe over
and over and over again she did it today
uh in various ways but i'm telling you
i'm telling you if you don't participate
if you don't participate we cannot rely
on
judges
in an administrative hearing down in
georgia and atlanta to save our asses
and save our democracy we must do it
ourselves that is how it's always been
done we the people can
can advocate for pro-democracy and
participate in it and that is how we do
it so um gabe thanks for sticking with
us all day and the kfa if you're out
there listening everyone go follow uh
midas minus touch's legal af podcast now
go listen to karen uh on her wednesday
episode and listen to the saturday
episode i'm sure ben myself and michael
popock will have a lot to say about this
hearing today um tomorrow on their
episode they'll air it on youtube and
then i think on sunday is when they air
it on the um
the podcast directories but go check
that out make sure to follow karen on
twitter at kfa legal thank you karen for
your commentary today thank you
everybody for joining us i think i'm
gonna go have a beer and a nap i think
that's what i'm gonna do gabe what's
your what's your plans here that sounds
pretty good if you're in a nap are you
are you gonna do that are you do you
show the stream beer i don't know i
don't know why would you sodastream beer
oh it's already it's already carbonated
yeah but i've got a i've got a little
ksa uh
little kosh in the in the fridge waiting
for me you know so okay good good take a
little nap maybe have a little snack
okay good good good well go snack go
have a beer everyone have a great
weekend and until monday again noon
eastern 11 central every single weekday
monday through friday youtube twitter
twitch and now from the mind and such
facebook page remember
have a great weekend and surf's up
[ __ ] surf's up
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking